well it is a very very special day my
friends i'm so glad that you are here
i am ready i have my snacks i've got my
pumpkin seeds i've got walnuts should i
need a hit of protein
in the midst of this we are about to see
on what could not be a more perfect day
the
official process by which joe biden
will be uh on a path to be inaugurated
as the president of the united states
14 days from today scheduled to start in
just 10 minutes
donald trump is still ranting right now
trump is speaking with a mysterious vote
dump
of up to 100 000 votes for joe biden
trump still talking about these massive
dumps that he's convinced are going on
but it is about to start the action
is starting to let's see if we have any
audio here impress me this is there's
nothing remotely courageous
okay so we are uh just just getting
close to this joint session of the house
and senate
and really i mean listen the united
states is in a tough place right now
there's no doubt about it
pandemic economy etc but
we've removed donald trump joe biden is
coming in
democrats have taken the senate
officially called for raphael warnock
some calls for john ossoff and donald
trump
has lost everything donald trump lost
the house in 2018 for republicans
he was made a one-term president in
november
and he is now losing the senate and if
you want to hear
some sort of poetic justice we have also
just learned that merrick garland
will be joe biden's attorney general
mitch mcconnell dethroned as senate
majority leader
will now be under the thumb
of attorney general merrick garland
who he blocked from getting to the
supreme court
during barack obama's last year in
office
it is omega lull
i think is an accurate term for what is
taking place right now
and trump ranting from a behind a foot
of plexiglass listen to him continue 88
000 ballots in georgia were cast by
people
who's registered the crowd silent he's
re he's just
reading about supposed vote dumps it's
an unbelievable day it's really an
unbelievable day so i
am glad that you're here people are
already throwing memberships at me i
want to say thanks to michael
bull for signing up at joinpackman.com
jason
bank and john borgeson which already
puts us at three
we have a very special goal today 306
and you know what that number is we all
know what that number is
that is the number of electoral votes
that joseph r biden jr
secured in this election and uh we are
going to be going very very strongly
in that direction trump continuing to
rant
demanding mike pence steal it for him
and as you can see here
things are starting to happen waiting
for the c-span feed i really prefer the
c-span feed
but it is not yet live i just want to
have a couple of feeds ready for you
guys
uh this is going back to video of al
gore in the year 2000 who presided as
vice president over his own
the counting of his own defeat and we
are standing by here i believe this is
mitch mcconnell over here so it's all
happening
a really important symbolic super chat
gremlin just sent a super chat
for eleven thousand seven hundred and
eighty cents
you understand trump demanding on the
phone with brad raffensberger 11
780 votes gremlin
just supporting me with 11
780 pennies pennies
which we love and it is just going to be
crazy now
if your question is how long is this
going to go on i don't know the answer
there may be hours and hours of delays
and debates
we just don't know we're here to see um
and we know that 11 or maybe 12
republican senators plan
to object i object sir
uh we don't know how long they will be
able to extend it we are going to be as
i mentioned donald trump is still
speaking he's been going now for how
long has he been going let's see here
he's been going for about 55 minutes
he may be highly highly triggered on
twitter as the day goes on so we're
gonna i mean look at this
even mexico uses voter id he just
can't stop he can't stop so we'll be
watching the tweets
um earlier at this event by the way fox
news had to cut away from don jr
uh because don jr started ranting
profanely check this out
who could have seen that coming
i had no idea i'm glad donald trump jr
speaking to trump's supporters there in
washington
this is the save america rally happening
ahead of the certification of the
election
so even even uh fox news not able to
handle the hopped up rantings
of don jr and they they cut away from it
very very strongly so
uh we are watching what is taking place
on the floor of the house of
representatives anticipating the start
within just five minutes
of a joint session mike pence will
preside
and uh every every you know 20 different
things have been proposed as to what
will happen here but what we see
is that donald trump has left the
republican party in shambles and why
would it be anything else
donald trump comes through and destroys
businesses
donald trump comes through and destroys
relationships donald trump comes through
and declares bankruptcy
so donald trump got himself to be a
one-term president
and he lost the house to the democrats
and he lost the senate to the democrats
and then he's going to wash his hands of
it and leave although he is
still still still ranting as we speak
just listen this is in michigan detroit
michigan a career employee of the
detroit
city of detroit testified doesn't even
know what he's reading my friends
doesn't even know what he's reading all
100 senators although
uh there may be so i believe this is now
this is uh this is the senators going
over to the house
for the senators to go to the house they
must be invited it is sort of ceremonial
but not in the sense that senators don't
go to the house unless they're invited
to go to the house
and they're making their way across the
uh
central artery there at the u.s capitol
this is the senate you can tell from the
you know desks and size and the fact
that
almost everybody's 90 years old as we
have a very old senate in the united
states
they are making their way over to the
house of representatives
and uh this is now the house of
representatives
and this is the c-span feed which i
prefer so they are waiting
in the house this is now the house for
the senators to arrive and they will
soon
this is going to be a crazy crazy day um
and it's it's all finally finally going
to happen
i do want to say thank you to the one
two three four
24 thanks to a beautiful gift by
inconsolable 25
26 27 uh 27
twitch subscribers that have just
entered the fray
putting us at 30 and then listen guys
it's a better 2021 and that's why the
coupon code
is better21 uh at joinpakman.com
and i want to say thank you to the how
many people is it
uh nine additional people who just
grabbed memberships on my website
putting us at 39
it's now people joining and asking when
when when
it's now senators are making their way
from the senate over to the house of
representatives
speaker of the house nancy pelosi is
waiting there is
jim jordan um
looking up res old wrestling videos on
his phone i'm sure
waiting for things to happen as the
senators make their way over
republican senator josh hawley sort of
leading the pack
of delusional objections from republican
senators
and there's going to be a lot here
david asking where's the freaking gaba
ghoul
uh well that's a very entertaining story
but real detectives have to worry about
a little thing called evidence
lois einhorn yes uh from uh from ace
ventura
there is lunatic congressman louie
gohmert
and he is just a terrible terrible
person fundamentally
um and this is going to get underway
very very soon let's take a listen to
the soothing sounds
and remember as this is going on donald
trump
still ranting about massive dumps
supposed to be voting for they
make up whatever they want nobody's ever
even heard they adjudicate your
vote they say well we don't think trump
wants to vote this would be a great
split screen
to do trump ranting and ranting and
ranting and ranting and ranting for
hours
as the votes are all going to be counted
in the house of representatives now i do
want to tell you something
um people as of this morning are telling
me this isn't happening trump will be
president here's just two examples okay
this is from this morning man you were
so smart only playing clips of an
interview
you do understand biden did not win
there are seven or now
eight contested states i'm going to
really enjoy seeing your expression when
trump overturns this election
that's not from two months ago that's
from this morning
uh also this morning troy york
calling in he thinks that republic the
right the races in georgia are over
he thinks republicans will sweep this is
troy york this morning
david david packman um this is woody
underwood again
um it's really troy york not woody
underwood
calling back and i just want to say
before i was come up i think georgia
the republicans are going to sweep
georgia no they're not it's over that's
that's a call from this morning okay
they're in a fantasy world let's listen
as the senators
enter the house chamber to applause i
don't know why why are we clapping
oh wait or is that pence yeah it's pence
don't clap for pens what a clown
here we go
[Applause]
what a vile human
imagine being pelosi and having to deal
with this sycophant
uh oh are those the massive ballot dumps
are those the boxes alright so we still
have a few minutes as they get going
uh really we we are witnessing history
here my friends we are really witnessing
history here
um and it's going to be it is going to
be something else
i do want to say thanks to the 20 people
who just signed
up via twitch i do appreciate that
as well as the um
eight more who signed up on my website
joinpackman.com
and this is this is going to be
interesting what will penn say
what won't pence say what will we hear
from him
uh this is a joint session of the house
and senate
nancy pelosi apparently admonishing mike
pence about what is going to go
down here senators
filing in have been invited to the house
chamber
there's sherrod brown in the middle
that's pensen pelosi of course
you can tell who's in charge from the
body language here it's very clear who
is in charge
no question whatsoever dalton belby
says via super chat there's chuck
schumer i'm trying to get your
membership right now i'll be back
uh there's mitch mcconnell dethroned
powerfully as senate majority leader
isn't it great to see
mcconnell dethroned it is really great
for the world never mind the united
states it is a really really good thing
um still getting more and more callers
people saying
this isn't happening trump's going to be
president there's amy klobuchar as you
can see
talking to mike pence and nancy pelosi
everybody just sort of getting settled
and soon
the house will be called to order
i don't know if pence is allowed to be
that close to a woman without his wife
around that's a fair question i don't
know where my
mother is um she's probably lurking
somewhere
chaperoning in some sense uh so we're
getting there
is there a chance uh chance trump leads
the crowd to the joint session so
interestingly not only does the senate
need to be invited
to go to the house of representatives
the president also does and without an
invitation
trump is not allowed in the house
chamber that a lot of people may not
understand that that is not merely
procedural um trump's still ranting i
mean
still still going listen
they said it's not american to challenge
the election this is the most corrupt
election in the history maybe of the
world you know you could go third world
countries but i don't think they had
hundreds of thousands of votes and they
don't have voters for them i mean no
matter where you go nope
so trump completely delusional unable to
accept
reality as you can see this is texas
senator john cornyn right here
um that might be josh hawley i can't
totally tell with the masks it's sort of
tough
uh there is of course nancy pelosi
let us remind that each side house and
senate
democrats and republicans each have
11 members allowed to be present on the
floor
others may be in the gallery this is at
the guidance
of this uh officiating
attending physician and the sergeants at
arm
the gentleman on the republican side of
the eye will please
observe the social distancing
and agree to what we have good luck
members on each side
this audio is not good to this chamber
to this guys i'm gonna bail to better
audio
getting by the wall let's go let's just
start
here we go
all right
speaker pelosi gaveling this session to
order here's vice president pence
pence going masculist
and there's already people calling out
members of congress
pursuant to the constitution and the
laws of the united states
here we go the senate and house of
representatives are meeting in joint
session
to verify the certificates and count the
votes of the electors of the several
states
for president and vice president of the
united states
after ascertainment has been had that
the certificates are authentic
and correct in form the tellers will
count and make a list of the votes cast
by the electors of the several states
the tellers on the part of the two
houses
have taken their places at the clerk's
desk
without objection the tellers will
dispense with the reading
of the formal portions of the
certificates after ascertaining that the
certificates are regular in form and
authentic
the tellers will announce the votes cast
by the electors for each state beginning
with alabama
correct which the parliamentarians
advise me is the only certificate of
vote
from that state and purports to be a
return from the state
and that has annexed to it a certificate
from an authority of that state
purporting
to appoint or ascertain electors i
object
for what purpose does the gentleman from
virginia run here we go
parliamentary inquiry mr vice president
in order to follow with the speaker's
instructions that only a limited number
of people be on the floor
may i ask how one would make an
objection or make a parliamentary
inquiry in the future
if you're not on the floor but in the
gallery
these people are idiots
title three of the united states code uh
debate is not permitted in the joint
session
the parliamentary inquiry mr vice
president i am not a gentleman's rep
i'm not attempting to debate i'm trying
to find out how a parliamentary inquiry
or a parliamentary
point of order would be made in
following with the speaker's
uh request that comedy on the floor
how do you make one of those points of
order when you don't know what's going
to happen later
uh respectfully yes sir the gentleman's
parliamentary inquiry constitutes debate
which is not permitted in the joint
session oh my god
of title iii united states code didn't
know we were doing a cringe stream today
sir how can i start a coup
what a mess yeah just come on in
everybody come on in i'm welcome
everybody we're electing a president
here
despite the efforts being made president
this is roy blunt i believe i don't
believe it
a lot of debate as to whether the mics
are on which i love
soon we will determine which mics are on
and how the mics are controlled i i'm
confident that will happen
they're just dumping microphones having
microphone issues there
in the house of representatives senator
roy blunt of missouri one of the tellers
yeah let's see if they're back on here
could i get a little more kick drum in
the ear yeah thank you
an errant smack of the gavel
[Music]
i'm not getting nearly enough snare from
roy blunt in my earpiece
mr president order in the chamber mr
president the
gentleman will continue the certificate
of the electoral vote of the state of
alabama
seems to be regular informed and
authentic
and it appears therefrom that donald j
trump of the state of florida received
nine votes for president
and michael r pence of the state of
indiana received nine votes for vice
president
are there any objections to counting the
certificate of vote of the state of
alabama
that the teller has verified appears to
be regular informed and authentic
hearing none
this certificate from alaska the
parliamentarians advise me is the only
certificate of vote from that state that
purports to be a return from the state
what a time to be alive next to it a
certificate from an authority
is this on to appoint and ascertain
electors
mr president the certificate of the
electoral vote of the state of alaska
seems to be regular informed and
authentic
and it appears they're from that donald
j trump of the state of florida received
three votes for president
and michael r pence of the state of
indiana received three votes for vice
president
are there any objections to counting the
certificate of vote of the state of
alaska
that the teller has verified appears to
be regular information no
no
guys just a quick thing a lot of people
are saying why are they calling him mr
president the vice president is the
president
of the senate that's his capacity here
okay
hearing none this certificate from
arizona the parliamentarians advise me
is the only certificate of vote that the
state
we may get our first objection here that
has annexed a certificate from an
authority of that state
reporting to appoint or ascertain
electors
we may get an objection here mr
president the certificate of the
electoral vote
of the state of arizona seems to be
regular
informed and authentic and it appears
there from
that joseph r biden jr
of the state of delaware received 11
votes for president
and kamala d harris of the state of
california
received 11 votes for vice president
are there any objections to counting the
certificate of vote
of the state of arizona that the teller
is verified appears to be regular
informed and authentic
president i paul gosar from arizona what
purpose does the
gentleman from here we go i rise up
for myself and 60 of my colleagues to
object to the
accounting of the electoral ballots from
arizona it's all sweaty
is the objection in writing and signed
by a senator
yes it is it is oh god it's cruz oh my
god it was vile
imagine clapping for this
oh boy tomorrow's gonna be sad for these
guys huh
[Applause]
an objection presented in writing and
signed by both a representative
and a senator complies with the law
chapter one of title three of the united
states code
the clerk will report the objection
i has a coup
objection to counting the electoral
votes of the state of arizona
we a member of the house of
representatives
and a united states senator object to
the counting of the electorial votes of
the state of arizona
on the ground that they were not under
all of the known circumstances regularly
given
that's not going to stand my friends are
there further objections to the
certificates from the state
of arizona
the chair here's none the two houses
will withdraw
from joint session each house will
deliberate separately on the pending
objection
and report its decision back to the
joint session
so that's going to be the process retire
to its chamber
so this is the process they are going to
do this for every one of the states in
which they will be
objecting there will be a break
and there will be a debate and then
there will be a vote
there is no belief at this time
that republicans will be able to sustain
objections on any state at this point in
time
this is a waste of time this is a waste
of taxpayer dollars
this is not going to prevent joe biden
from being sworn in 14 days from now
but this is what republicans have chosen
to do
they are going to object uh at
minimum i would believe to six or so
states i assume they will object to
pennsylvania or pennsylvania as some say
i assume they will object in georgia
they've objected in arizona they may
object in nevada
they may object to wisconsin uh michigan
um they're coming from south america as
you i mean these things are real they're
really coming from everywhere so this is
going to be
the process it's suspect we are
suspended and shut down
at arizona and we'll see what the debate
is going to look like we'll see how long
they really want to drag this out
but this could go very late into the
night uh if there are six
sets of objections and two hours of
debate on each
that's 12 hours that puts us at 1 16 a.m
in the morning and that doesn't encount
going
count going back and forth and accepting
some of the votes
so if it's interrupted
that often and they will continue to
strike and strike
and strike we could be looking at 18
hours of this
we could be looking at 16 hours of this
uh
you know i i i we don't know but they
will now retire to their respective
chambers as you can see they are cal
carrying out each time apparently they
will be carrying out the ballots
and then bringing them back now in the
meantime
the donald trump lunatic march has ended
and
aaron rupar does have clips i don't know
if while they get resettled
you guys want to look at some of the
clips from trump that would be something
we can do trump again dancing to ymca
[Music]
just moments ago as he wrapped um i
don't know how long it will take them to
get uh
set back up there but this is going to
be quite a quite a process
i want to say a huge thank you
to the three additional now 39 people
who grabbed memberships at
joinpackman.com i really do appreciate
that
um and then i also very much appreciate
the four folks
who just signed up on twitch putting us
at 102.
uh we do have a goal of 306 today one
for each
electoral vote that joe biden
has obtained um
so this is the key question via super
chat will the objection do anything
realistically no
no um trump said he's marching down to
the house with them i would love video
of that
let's see if we can find any video of
that
um let's see
do we have any video trump march
live i would love to find video of that
but i am just not seeing it
oh hold on maybe now i'm i'm unable to
find if trump is marching to the house
i would be interested in uh seeing that
but i am not i am not seeing that now
for people asking didn't they do this on
december 14th
on december 14th each state voted
now they are counting those votes in
washington dc
on the 14th everything happened in the
states
now it's all being done in washington
d.c
uh let's take a little bit of a listen
to an update as to what's going on
yeah and we see the the speaker of the
house nancy pelosi she
remains in the chair in the chamber
what what will she be doing today right
she has said that she will
um be in the chair during these
objections during debate
questioning the validity of
president-elect joe biden's electoral
votes
of course she rarely presides over the
chamber which she leads
that is usually not uh only during very
big moments we saw it during the end of
impeachment we see it during the start
of a new congress
right um and other key details
all right so we're going to continue
keeping an eye on what goes on here
everybody now just waiting for this
debate
to start uh debate will happen in the
house and senate
separately and that is what we are
standing by for
um at this point in time welcome to
everybody who is joining us we do
have uh we've got a great crowd here
today actually we've got what is that
three and three is six carry the
throughput 53 000 folks watching with us
today
and the drama will uh escalate
momentarily as we will actually
hear what exactly will be the
um factual and by factual i mean alleged
factual basis of these objections
from republicans of course republicans
losing control of the senate with the
two wins in georgia yesterday early this
morning by rafael warnock
uh remember radical liberal raphael
warnock
is now going to be rafa radical liberal
senator raphael warnock john ossoff as
well
um very very important stuff taking
place here
carlos says i have to say this is
gut-wrenching the united states as we
know it
died today let's hear what's going on in
the house may 4th
2021 in accordance with the guidance
and advice of the attending physician
members advise to remain in the chamber
only if they are participating in debate
and must wear a mask at all times even
when
under recognition for debate wow members
must
also practice proper social distancing
when present in the chamber let the
records show
that there is a gross violation of this
guidance from this
attendance on the republican side of the
aisle
please in the interest of your own
health discussion
as an example to the american people
abide by the numbers
now up to 25 on each side
of the aisle to participate in this
stage
of the development okay pursuant to
senate concurrent resolution one
pursuant to senate concurrent resolution
one and section
17 of title iii congress of the us
united states code when the two houses
withdraw
from the joint session to count the
electoral vote
for separate consideration of an
objection a representative may speak to
the
objection for five minutes and not more
than once
debate shall not exceed two hours after
which the share will put in
the question shall the objection be
agreed to
the clerk will report the objection so
meanwhile guys
there is now an attempt being made to
breach the barriers at the capitol
they are becoming violent look at this
they are trying to force their way into
the capital this is a violent
uprising from pro-trump lunatics look at
this
this is live
what is wrong with the country
oh now they don't like police i guess
look at this they're trying to breach
the barrier
[Music]
[Applause]
businesses in dc widely boarded up
because of the anticipation of exactly
this and look at this they are trying to
force their way in
i guess they think entering the capital
will make trump president
somehow
and then meanwhile inside the chamber
the debate continues let's hear from
steve scalise why he thinks
biden shouldn't be president i guess
speaker in a number of those states
that constitutional process was not
followed and that's why we're here to
object if you look
at what the requirement says nowhere in
article 2 section 1 does it
give the secretary of state of a state
that ability
nowhere does it give the governor that
ability nowhere does it give
a court that ability it exclusively
gives that ability
to the legislatures and in fact in most
states that's the process that was
followed
but for those states that this wasn't
followed
unfortunately this is not new we've seen
over and over again more states where
the democrat party has gone in
and selectively gone around this process
yeah that has just happens to be the
states trump needs to win
follow the constitutional process
okay they are pepper spraying trumpists
i am being told
the debate going on inside is ridiculous
outside you can hear it sounds like a
those
canisters gas canisters
what is that noise is that are they are
police deploying
they're trying to force their way into
the u.s capitol as we speak
[Applause]
and as you can see they are trying to
just maintain
[Music]
oh and there oh wow got sprayed right in
the face
oh my god it is getting aggressive
[Music]
point-blank spray in the face
oh god is that they're deploying the gas
the the spray rather very liberal oh and
now they're getting this guy's getting
[Music]
pushed
and he's casually drinking water
[Music]
how is this happening in this country
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
oh some of these people are actually
deliberately scuffling with law
enforcement even
now if the profile of some of these
folks were different would people have
gotten shot already i mean i'm asking
that seriously
[Music]
the people who for the last six months
have said police brutality is not a
problem
in the next six hours all they're going
to talk about is how police brutality is
a problem
so that's outside the capital that's
outside the capital
inside the capital things that make just
as little censor going on
here is steve scalise with a sort of
problematic mask
explaining why biden shouldn't get the
votes
from arizona every single democrat voted
against it
they don't want to fix this problem
but the constitution is our guide
and it's time we start following the
constitution it's time we get back
to what our founding father said is the
process for selecting electors that's
the legislatures
in public view not behind closed doors
not smoke-filled rooms
not bullying somebody that might give
you a better ruling let's get back to
rule
of law and follow the constitution madam
speaker and i yield back the balance of
my time
now he was only supposed to have five
minutes total it seems he went longer
but what purpose does the gentlewoman
you know i actually think democrats
shouldn't even participate like i know
they will because they'll say
everything's fine everything's normal i
actually think the democrats shouldn't
even participate just let the
republicans rant and then go to the
votes and get back to the joint session
and count the next statement
madam speaker this day marks a
crossroads for american democracy
those who objected the counting of the
electoral college votes
which reflect the votes of the american
people wants to set want to substitute
their preferences for the voters choice
that's not what our constitution
requires and it's at odds with the
american democratic republic
if congress selects the next president
instead of american voters
will have no need for an electoral
college in fact we'd have no need for
presidential elections at all
we'd be moving from a government elected
by the people
to a government selected by those
already governing
that's not america in the united states
we abide by the choices of the people
not an elite few
the framers of our constitution
considered whether to have congress
select the president
and specifically rejected it instead
they wrote article 2 and the 12th
amendment
article two creates the electoral
college where each state appoints
electors
so zoe lofgren simply explaining this is
not how it works
um the same debate in the house
being covered here by cbs news
and then this exact same uh statement
being covered by
pbs and this is part of the first
objection if you're just joining us
we got through alabama and alaska and
when we got to arizona
an objection was heard from the floor
the joint sessions separated the senate
will debate for up to two hours
the house for up to two hours there is
the expectation that there will
be will be objections to six or seven
different
states if there are two hours for each
of those
plus some additional time we're
expecting that there could be about
16 hours of this just a very very rough
estimate
i have no intention of streaming all of
it uh my idea is to be here
for some time and then i'm gonna take a
break work on tomorrow's show and get
some other things done and then
i will probably be just be back tonight
when hopefully we will be getting back
to
uh we will be at i don't know maybe by
the states that start with the letter d
by tonight or something like that um i
am curious whether there will be snacks
served for these folks yeah because
they're going to be here for a long time
now
if you want to understand the level of
violence that is starting
um oh this is the senate chamber now in
the meantime mitch mcconnell is over
there
uh pro-trump protesters are right
outside the capitol trying to breach
they are physically trying to get in
they are scuffling with and attacking
officers of the law who they claim to
respect people have been pepper sprayed
this is happening
just feet feet from where this is going
on
the other stuff is going on let's listen
a little bit to the senate hitting a
step
that has never been taken in american
history
and remember mcconnell is is not
participating in these objections from
my understanding
and overturn a presidential
election
i've served 36 years in the senate
imagine being mitch mcconnell and on the
day that you find out you're losing
your senate majority leadership you also
have to go out there and admonish your
fellow republicans for
trying to steal an election this has got
to be one of the worst days in mitch
mcconnell's political career
obligations to constitutional arguments
to sweeping conspiracy theories
wow i supported the president's right
to use the legal system
dozens of lawsuits
received hearings in courtrooms all
across our country
but over and over
the courts rejected these claims
including all-star judges whom the
president himself has nominated
every election we know features some
illegality
and irregularity and of course that's
unacceptable
i support strong state-led voting
reforms
last year's bizarre pandemic procedures
must not become the new norm
but my colleagues nothing before us
proves
illegality anywhere near
the massive scale
the massive scale that would have
tipped the entire election
nor can public doubt alone
justify a radical break
when the doubt itself
was incited without any evidence right
what he's saying basically is
your feelings can't override the facts
here and that and mitch mcconnell is
is absolutely right about that and as
you can tell
obviously he is under the thumb of the
chinese communist party there's no other
way that mitch mcconnell could have come
to this conclusion
that's a joke that's a joke so debate
happening in the senate
debate happening in the house here is
jim shorts jordan
objecting i object we asked chairman
nadler chairwoman maloney
for an investigation they said no
wouldn't want to investigate something
that
half the electorate has doubts about
it's just the presidency of the united
states
why why not one single investigation why
not even one single hearing over the
last nine weeks in the united states
house of representatives why
because there's no evidence making sure
president trump isn't president
for four and a half years that's all
they've cared about
july 31st 2016 before he was elected the
first time
jim comey's fbi takes out the insurance
i
i cannot in good conscience broadcast to
you
jim jordan's rantings we're talking
about james comey now
now you're raising you're raising james
comey
so what republicans are doing in the
house of representatives
is disgusting what republicans are doing
in the uh senate chamber is disgusting
now mitch mcconnell happens not to be
joining them i i want to be clear mitch
mcconnell's
disgusting and he's losing his
leadership because they lost georgia
today
and he's horrible he's not participating
in this
and that's good but what republicans are
trying to do in the senate
is also disgusting and meanwhile
right outside this this is at the
capitol
lunatic trumpists they've now picked up
a barricade
they are trying to force their way into
the capital to disrupt what is going on
the pepper spray is being released it's
free-flowing
look at this
[Music]
sounds like bombs are going on
[Music]
i understand why businesses in dc have
been boarded up
i understand why people i know who who
live in dc
are uh are are staying staying home or
even out look they've picked up barriers
and they're trying to
look at what is going on
the left is so violent right i mean look
at this
wow this is the united states
how dare you trade her the police are
the traders i guess
oh wow a lot of pepper sprays flying
around here
[Applause]
[Music]
um
unbelievable remember things were going
to be crazy in joe biden's america
these are trumpists while trump is
president
trying to execute a coup and oh there's
the pepper spray again
at what point do we say it's an attempt
at a violent coup i mean is
they they want the guy who lost to be
president and they are becoming violent
to make that a reality at some point
isn't this a violent coup attempt
in other words it's no longer just
rhetoric
[Applause]
look at this guy no mask
[Music]
what insanity
this is on a channel called status ku
it's a pro-trump channel is my
understanding this is
the people asking this is i believe it's
a pro-trump channel
[Applause]
i mean listen some of these people are
going to end up
getting the crap kicked out of them by
police if they haven't already there's
there's no question you
you can't uh and there they go wow with
more of the pepper spray
is that a pepper spray gun is this guy
about to go point blank in this guy's
[Music]
face
wow this is really really depressing
[Applause]
and as you can see there's all sorts of
layers of backup i mean even if they
were able to breach
this line of security i don't think
they're breaching the ones that's up on
the stair i just don't think they're
getting in today
um and i think if there was any chance
that they would the national guard would
would be deployed but how
i mean i want to say it's ironic but the
same people before who were saying
deploy the national guard because of the
george floyd protests
uh they are the ones now who may cause
the national guard
to have to be deployed it's it's just
absolutely unbelievable
and meantime here is adam schiff in the
house of representatives as debate
happens about the arizona electoral
votes
that we are here with a substantial
number of our members seeking to
overturn an election is remarkable
tragic and all too predictable
ford is the natural result of a
locomotive set in motion months ago with
a myth
for weeks and weeks before during and
after our election a dangerous falsehood
was propagated
that our election would be marred by
massive fraud
never mind it was the same election
which brought the very men
and women to this chamber who would
challenge its results what value has
consistency
when measured against ambition a former
senator from georgia
remarking on a contested election over a
century ago
said that able men learned men
distinguished men great men in the eyes
of the nation
seemed intent only on accomplishing a
party triumph
without regard to the consequences to
the country
that is human nature that is he said
unfortunately
party nature was he right
we stand in a house which was once the
place of giants
have we become so small
does our oath to uphold the constitution
taken just
days ago mean so very
little i think not
i believe to quote our dear departed
friend elijah cummings that we
are better than that this is completely
completely surreal
uh here is the senate chuck schumer
today it will be confirmed once again
something that is well known and well
settled
the american people elected joe biden
and kamala harris to be the next
president
and vice president of the united states
and yet a number of our colleagues have
organized an effort
to undermine and object to that free and
fair election
they're in the minority they will lose
they know that they have no evidence of
widespread voter fraud upon which to
base their objections
that's because there is none there is
none
not brought before any of the courts
successfully
they know that president trump and his
allies have suffered the defeat
a defeat in court in court after court
across the country losing no fewer than
62
legal challenges and i might add many
republican appointed judges
some appointed by president trump
rendered those decisions
they know you all know
joe biden and kamala harris are going to
be sworn
in as president and vice president of
the united states
on january 20th
but they are going to object to the
counting of the vote anyway
and in the process they will embarrass
themselves
they will embarrass their party and the
country
and worst of all they will embarrass
their country there it is this
insurrection
was fortunately discouraged
by the leadership of the majority party
true but it was not quelled
it is a very sad comment on our times
that merely the accepting the results of
an election
is considered an act of political
courage
sadder and more dangerous still is the
fact that an element of the republican
party
believes their political viability
hinges on the endorsement of an
attempted
coup
that anyone much less an elected
official
would be willing to tarnish our
democracy in order to burnish their
willing their eager
fortunes
over the course of the afternoon and
however far
into the evening this band of republican
objectors wants to take
us right senators of goodwill from both
sides of the aisle
we'll explain why these challenges must
be dismissed
the senators from states whose electoral
votes are being challenged
will explain how the allegations of
fraud are baseless
yeah so let me give everybody a reset
because you're if you're just joining us
um i
i do see that we have um a total of 70
000 people watching and i know many of
you have only been here for the last 15
minutes so let me just give you a reset
as to what it is that is going on
11 a.m this morning donald trump or he
was an hour late but
supposedly at 11 am this morning donald
trump was speaking at some rally to
steal the election
supporting this coup um at 1 p.m eastern
time
a joint session of the house and senate
began this means senators
walk from the senate over to the house
the house is much larger and if they are
to meet together they must do it on the
side of the house
and under the stewardship of vice
president mike pence
they started counting electoral votes
now remember
the electoral votes were cast on
december 14th
no votes are being cast here they are
merely being counted it is
essentially ceremonial unless a state
has failed
to vote in this case no state failed to
vote
every state voted on december 14th they
got through alabago alphabetically they
got through alabama
they got through alaska and when they
got to arizona republicans stood up and
objected
that objection uh
that objection triggers up to two hours
of the of debate the joint session
dissolves the senators have walked back
to the senate
that's this debate going on the members
in the house of representatives
are in this debate over in the house and
after up to two hours they will vote
as to whether to uphold the objection on
not counting
the vote from arizona or whether to
count it we already know
that republicans don't have the vote in
either chamber
republicans don't have the vote in
either chamber and this is simply going
to delay
what is obviously going to happen now in
the meantime
there is a violent insurrection of
trumpists
that are just a few hundred feet from
where this is going on
this is going on they have been uh
physically
battling with police they have been
trying to
push these uh barriers and
and essentially breach the security and
get into
the capitol building and these folks
walked
over many of them from donald trump's
speech the president of the united
states
incited this and you see that uh
the now things have calmed down a little
but then the scuffles go and then the
pepper
spray comes out there's the pepper spray
again um and i don't know how long this
is going to go on
um i don't know which will go on longer
i don't know if this will go on longer
or this is going to go on longer um it's
it's unclear
at this point in time and now in the
meantime i do want to mention one other
thing
in the midst of all of this chaos
the dow jones industrial average is up
600 points
and of course there is never
any way to say for sure why a market
does anything
okay but um
it it seems as though what's going on
which is we are formalizing the win of
joe biden
we know that there will be democratic
control of the senate these things
at minimum are not spooking the market
and we're now thinking about a two
thousand dollar uh
per person stimulus and uh
bitcoin has also exploded i mean it's
all crazy where is bitcoin
right now um
bitcoin is up another three percent up
to 35 that is insane
um yeah i i've disclosed i mean i i said
on january 1st i sold 15
of my bitcoin just to lock things in uh
but because it's exploded even more in
in these last few days um
i i've ended up with more i mean it's
just crazy what's going on it's it's
insane what's what's happening here
um but that is that is basically what we
are watching right now
this is outside of the capitol building
this is in the senate and then this is
in the house of representatives and this
could go
well well into the night depending on
how many objections we are expecting
uh let's see what's happening the
gentleman for what purpose does the
gentleman from maryland seek
recognition madam speaker i rise in
opposition to the objection
the gentleman is recognized without
objection for five minutes
madam speaker i want to thank you first
and and all my dear beloved colleagues
for your love and tenderness which my
family and i
will never forget his son just died it's
horrible
absolutely horrible oh there's our
friend hakeem jeffries right here he's
been on the show before there is nice
guy
thank you again abraham lincoln
whose name is a comfort to us all
said we've got the best government the
world ever knew
it's best because the first three words
of the constitution
tell us who governs here
we the people watch this proceeding
today
and tell the world with pride as lincoln
did
about the brilliant meaning and promise
of our country
our government belongs to the people
as president ford said here the people
rule
today we are in the people's house to
complete the people's process
for choosing the people's president now
meanwhile
unfortunately because of growing unrest
from this pro-trump rally
evacuations have started in washington
d.c
evacuations at multiple buildings at u.s
capitol complex
amid dc protests evacuate madison
due to police activity occupants should
remain calm and move in a safe manner to
the exits
take enunciators on the way out close
doors behind you proceed immediately to
your designated assembly area
this is happening capitol police have
evacuated staffers from the madison and
cannon buildings at the capitol complex
amid protests in washington dc the
evacuations from the building come amid
protests over congress's certification
of the electoral vote
inside the chamber has remained calm and
for people asking if they've breached
the building
they have not they have not breached the
building this is all happening outside
for the time being
i don't believe there is any way they
are going to be able to breach the
building there is
one line of uh of police well outside
the building
and another one on the stairs although
i'm trying to figure out what is this
guy doing what is he doing is he tr what
is he trying to rip open here
you see this guy here he looks like he's
trying to i don't know what this is a
door to
see there oh now he pressed he white
okay and then he's going in
and now he's cutting with a knife
[Music]
remember guys this is just property
damage so we don't have to worry
they're cutting their way in i don't
know what this is this sometimes they
use these tents to create a perimeter
it's sort of an
outdoor indoor transition space where
you have security here's a guy just
cutting it all apart
yep these are these are the people who
said when a window broke during the
george floyd protests that
you know that should be a long time in
jail they're cutting their way in here
oh but he's coming up against metal look
at that what a disappointment
unbelievable
[Music]
[Applause]
what do they think is going to happen
you think you're going
look at this you think you're going to
get in and chuck schumer will say
you know what guys you're right let's
give it to trump because you cut your
way into the tent
now this guy is signaling for people to
go in
[Applause]
this is just a tragedy
[Music]
this is a tragedy and meanwhile the
debate continues wasting
so here we have destruction of of
federal property that's costing you
money that's costing me money
here we have a waste of taxpayer money
because ted cruz is ranting let's listen
to ted cruz
to count the votes the framers knew what
they were doing when they gave
responsibilities to congress
we have a responsibility
and i would urge that we follow the
precedent of 1877.
oh dear god the electoral count act
explicitly allows objections such as
this one
for votes that were not regularly given
of course they were let me be clear this
objection is for the state of arizona
but it is broader than that
we know it is an objection for all six
of the contestants
he'll be do they'll be doing this all
night objective
impartial body hear the evidence
and make a conclusive determination
that would benefit both sides
that would improve legitimacy of this
election
and so let me urge my colleagues
all of us take our responsibility
seriously right yeah we can tell
urge my colleagues don't take perhaps
the easy path
but instead act together astonish
the viewers and act in a bipartisan
sense to say
we will have a credible and fair
tribunal consider the claims consider
the facts
consider the evidence and make a
conclusive determination whether and to
what extent
this election complied with the
constitution give me a break
senator from minnesota mr president i
first would like to say i appreciate
the words of our leader senator schumer
as well
as senator mcconnell's call for a higher
calling
january 6 is not typically a day of
historical significance for our country
for centuries
this day is simply the day that we
receive each state's
certified electoral votes amy's going to
clobber everybody
without much fanfare in fact this is
only the third time in 120 years that
the senate has gathered to debate
an objection and as senator cruz well
knows
both times these objections were
resoundingly defeated the last time the
vote was 74-1
why because senators have long believed
that they should not mess around with
the will of the people they have
understood the words of
our great former colleague john mccain
from the state of arizona
who once said that nothing in life i see
people just joining us
asking what is really the most important
question will this make any difference
and the answer is no the answer is no
this will delay the inevitable and uh
republicans have forced this upon us and
it could be
six hours it could be eight hours it
could be
a lot more time this is lunatic
republican lauren beauberg she's
really bonkers in arizona the deadline
for voter registration for the 2020
presidential election
was october 5 2020 using covid
as a reasoning democrats filled a loss
filed a lawsuit
to extend this deadline by 18 days
and an injunction was made by an obama
appointed judge preventing the
arizona secretary of state from
enforcing the constitutional deadline
set
by the state legislature as a result of
this frivolous
partisan lawsuit ten extra days
were added via judicial fiat
to allow voter registration it was
apparently a stick shift fiat 500
actually that they did it by i would try
decaf if i were her i think i would
switch to decaf right away
so so this is what we have we have no
other choice uh that we we we can only
wait and see
how long uh how long this goes on i
apologize i've fallen
so behind in thanking people who have
been supporting
i do want to thank 27 more people who
just grabbed
twitch subscriptions which puts us at
146
and also everybody who's been signing up
on my website joinpackman.com
an additional uh 16 of you which puts us
at 162. i really appreciate that
and uh we've been doing a lot of
streaming and extra stuff this week
best way to just kind of uh say we like
it show your support is go to
joinpackman.com
and grab one of those memberships let's
tune back in here
the house will be in order
if we allow state election laws as set
forth by state legislatures to be
ignored and manipulated on the whims of
partisan lawsuits
unelected bureaucrats unlawful
procedures and arbitrary rules
then our constitutional republic will
cease to
exist the open i don't know why she's
yelling this past sunday to defend
and support the constitution makes it
necessary
for me to object to this travesty
otherwise the laws passed by the
legislative
branch merely become suggestions to be
accepted
rejected or manipulated by those who did
not
pass them madam speaker i have
constituents outside this building right
now i promised my voters to be
their voice this is what they're doing
which i now serve
it is my separate but equal obligation
to weigh in on this election
and object are we not a government of
buying for the people
they know that this election is not
right and as their representative i am
sent here to rep resent them i will not
allow the people to be ignored madam
speaker it is my duty under the u.s
constitution to object to the counting
of the electoral votes of the
state of arizona yeah you said that
already stand here today and accept
the results of this concentrated
coordinated
partisan effort by democrats where every
fraudulent vote
cancels out the vote of an honest
america has sided
with the extremists left the united
states congress needs to make an
informed decision
and that starts with this objection i
yield the balance of my time to the
gentleman from florida
mr brianman if she spoke louder and
faster i might be more convinced
madam speaker i rise as well to support
the objection
and i rise with a simple question
can the chair honestly tell americans
that with pending supreme court
legislation
lie pending supreme court case over
legal observers
not being allowed to observe and inspect
signatures
that the laws and constitution of that
state were not violated to change voting
outcomes madam speaker i will wait for a
response
25 seconds remaining i will repeat my
question can you honestly
tell americans oh that's great with
pending supreme court case
over legal observers not being able to
observe and inspect signatures
that the laws and constitution of
arizona
did not be violated to change voting
outcomes and i will wait for a response
okay the gentleman's time has expired
what purpose does the gentleman from
colorado oh i love it
madam speaker i rise in opposition to
the objection
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for five minutes
madam speaker today is an important day
in 1862 oh man the depths of the civil
war this is this is all just going
absolutely nowhere
um okay so so we're we're still in
objection number one just as a reminder
to everybody this is what's going on in
the senate
we've seen what's going on in the house
and uh it's not a bad use of time just
wait for nancy pelosi to answer
and this is what's going on outside now
do people know
whether the plan is for the protesters
to stay
like how long are they planning to stay
are they going to kind of tire
themselves out i'm
not really sure i understand what what
their plan is
quite frankly
oh that sounds like alex jones is that
jones
oh no we're losing the feed
that's too bad yeah and it's just that
feed in particular that we're losing
let's see if i refresh it that that
sounded very much like alex
jones
[Applause]
oh the feeds coming in and out that's
too bad
hmm if anybody knows of some other feeds
that are there i'd definitely be
open to uh actually oh wait a second i
thought i had another one actually
yeah a lot of the people sound like alex
jones to be perfectly frank
[Applause]
okay i'm told that woke twitch has some
content
so we'll let that load
oh i see yeah
yeah there seems to be a lot of insanity
going on here
it's it's chaos right now guys it's
absolute and total chaos as this all
uh continues the house and senate
debating together
and now it looks like this uh
contingent of people is on the move i
don't know exactly
where they're going um
[Music]
but they seem to be going so i don't
know if it's time for snacks maybe then
maybe they're just going to
pizza but they're going they're going
somewhere sort of becoming nomadic to
some degree
okay i i do apologize oh trump tweeted
hold on let me get to that
if donald trump tweeted we want to see
what he's saying now
13 minutes ago he tweeted oh he just
tweeted video of himself speaking
earlier
okay um let's look at a couple of clips
of that
here is donald trump uh let's let's
start at the top
start at the beginning of this very very
strange speech
a lot of clips from our friend aaron
rupar
um here's trump's arrival
trump's mic i guess didn't work for a
while
oh that's perfect
that's the best oh
man the mic just didn't work
that's too bad huh everything about this
presidency has become really sad
just kind of waiting
and he's pointing to people and nobody
in here
media will not show the magnitude of
this crowd
[Music]
oh that's just fantastic um okay here we
go trump claims there's hundreds of
thousands of people there
when i turned on today i looked and i
saw
thousands of people here but you don't
see hundreds of thousands of people
behind you because they don't want to
show that
we have hundreds of thousands of people
here and i really
want them to be recognized by the fake
news media turn your cameras please
and so trump doing that routine trump
saying here he will never concede
all of us here today do not want to see
our election
victory stolen by emboldened radical
left democrats which is what they're
doing
and stolen by the fake news media that's
what they've done
and what they're doing we will never
give up we will never concede it doesn't
happen
you don't concede when there's theft
involved well you'll just be gone i
guess
third world countries now never been
anything like that
you could take third world countries
just take a look take
third world countries their elections
are more honest than what we've been
going through in this country
it's a disgrace okay
and then here he is saying hopefully
mike pence does the right thing today
and of course
pence can't do anything and i hope mike
is gonna do the right thing i hope so
i hope so because if mike pence does the
right thing
we win the election all he has to do
all in this is this is from the number
one or certainly one of the top
constitutional lawyers in our country he
has the absolute right to do it
we're supposed to protect our country
support our country
support our constitution and protect our
constitution
states want to revoke all right so there
is
that that's trump earlier and i don't
know how worth it is to keep looking at
that
i'm told dylan burns is in
dc right now at the protest um
seems to be in an alley of some kind not
super compelling stuff
but we will keep an eye on that um
another
apparent confrontation here and
continuing to watch
uh what is going on let's listen report
uh the the counting that leads to
victory by joe biden he didn't recognize
joe biden's victory for many weeks i
think it was
at least a month after the election and
most republicans in the house and
certainly a large number most of those
in the senate
essentially went along with the
president's questioning election results
for week after week
during which time americans who support
the president
felt that all right i'm being told that
the protesters have now made it up
the steps and are actually getting
closer to breaching
um one line of security at least at the
house of representatives and if that's
the case
it could go it could get very very scary
very quickly
uh here is a combination oh yeah look at
this
uh stephen ignoramus has it
let's see if we can find that this is
just
tragic this is really really tragic if
that's what's going on
um stephen ignoramus
youtube steven ignoramus
seems to have that feed um
and here they are yeah it does appear as
though they
have at least made it onto the steps and
um
police are going to have to do something
about it yep they're at the steps wow
wow they're actually trying to force
their way into the building and there
seems to be just
one door there
[Applause]
i mean this is a this is a crowd this
size could absolutely break
the door down i think
[Applause]
all right and then i'm told that on
global news
there's actually been an explosion
audible of some kind let's see what's
happening here
oh wow they're they're up there yeah
this is much worse than i imagined
imagine if they start actually trying to
destroy columns or
or actually i mean listen guys if these
weren't pro-trump people but this was a
group of black folks
or muslim folks would this would this
even remotely be allowed like am i
am i crazy to be asking that at this
point
isn't it is it insane for me to wonder
whether this would be different
it seems most of the most of the
audience agrees that that would be a
very different situation going on here
they're essentially occupying the us
capital at least externally on some uh
balconies and the like this is
absolutely crazy and here it does seem
as though they are trying to push the
door in
it does appear that that is the goal at
this point in time
[Applause]
if you're just joining us buildings in
dc around the capitol have been
evacuated due to protesters that are
trying to break in essentially
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
and by the way way how many people are
going to end up with covid as a result
of this right that's another question
which is a completely fair and
reasonable question to ask things for
the time
being uh still calm
inside as you can see this is the senate
let's listen mr president i'll
yield up to five minutes to the senator
from oklahoma senator langford
senator from oklahoma
mr president in america we settle our
differences in elections
what happens if you don't trust the
election count or you're concerned that
so many courts
denied or dismissed cases within hours
after they were given thousands of pages
of evidence
the reason we have a congress to settle
our nation's divisions and the rules
of the senate make sure that every
opinion in the nation is heard is so
issues like this can be addressed
the constitutional crisis in our country
right now
is that millions of americans are being
told to sit down
and shut up wow yeah so he's completely
out of his mind and he's been one of the
most extreme senate members for a while
and then oh this is our friend raul
grijalva he's been on the program before
let's listen to him he's from arizona
great congressman
let's listen you additionally discarded
french conspiracy theories
but for the record let's talk a little
bit about arizona
arizona and state and local
officials did an unbelievable job
to ensure that the 220 elections ran
smoothly
mr hickman the republican chairman of
the maricopa
county party the largest county in the
state of arizona said
no matter how you voted this election
was administered with integrity
transparency and in accordance with
state laws
arizona showed up to the polls in record
numbers more than 3.4 million people
voted
increases in every county and a 65
percent
of all eligible voters in arizona voted
in the 2020 election
arizona's cast their ballots up and down
for republicans and democrats
and 11 electoral votes so listen i see
people in
in the chat saying that i don't get how
serious this is no no no i do it this is
gonna go on for hours and hours so i
don't know if people want me screaming
or what it is you expect me to do but
there is no
possible way that with language we can
overstate the seriousness of this
we have a significant portion of
federal elected republicans who are
openly trying to execute a coup for the
president in an election that they lost
and at the same time the supporters
of that president who lost are
physically
trying to break in to
the u.s capitol building they're they
are actually up the steps and at a door
and it is conceivable that they will be
able to break their way in
this is a global embarrassment
this sets absolutely insane
precedent for the future of the united
states
and there is no possible way to
overstate how crazy this is
so anybody what what i don't know what
you want me to do
if you want me to start you know
punching my microphone or bashing my
head into the
this is uh this is a tragedy of
unspeakable proportions
happening to to american democracy and
it's happening during a hundred year
pandemic
um and we'll and there's people
everywhere with no masks
um this is a uh this this is what i mean
listen is it is it crazy to say
failed state or or a would be
failed state like in other words biden
will eventually be president
if the national guard has to come out
they will
but if they got their way it would be a
failed state
like if these guys got their way
and then these guys got their way
it would be a failed state um
there's there's no question about that
uh but hopefully we will be able to
resist that but i would be very careful
if i was in washington dc right now
i don't know if any of these people have
jobs that's a fair question
that's an absolutely fair question um
and if they do you know i guess they can
afford to take the day off but they they
are pushing and pushing and trying to
breach that door and as you can see the
scrum continues to advance
towards the door uh
i do want to say thank you to everybody
who's watching
a very special shout out to everybody
watching on twitch we've committed to
twitch for 2021
and we're here and i really appreciate
everybody who's been signing up
and uh there's an additional 16 folks
who just grabbed twitch subs
and i want to thank you guys that puts
us at 178 and then of course
make sure you're following us on all
these platforms we're going to do some
more coverage take a break i'll work on
tomorrow's show a little bit and i'll be
back with more this is going to go into
the night
and unfortunately it could get even
crazier into the night
if you're watching on youtube we do have
68 000 people who just uh
joined us on youtube uh we do streams
like this all the time if you're
wondering who i am if you don't like me
then there's many other streams but if
you like our coverage
please do hit that subscribe button um
we have seen the subscribe button break
actually during some recent streams
because so many people
hit it so make sure to hit that
subscribe button on youtube
and also a big thank you to the nine
additional folks who signed up on my
website
putting us at 187 now i'm told that
there is action
uh in the senate let's take a listen
also as a threat to the electoral
college
which is something republicans have been
supportive of the electoral college
traditionally and now it does look like
proceedings have been stopped in the
senate
um do we know why they stopped them in
the senate pence they
they evacuated pence is that true for
security reasons
is that actually what happened objecting
uh
uh votes because there was something
wrong with the state's electoral system
congress is going to have to write rules
for those state electoral systems
and that congress has not that different
states have different practices so that
this would lead to
federalizing let me look at that
election laws which is something again
the republicans have tended
to oppose so i think it's been
interesting that
here i will call them conservative
objections
uh sort of conservative objections to
congress doing this and not just
objections based on the actual uh
who you want to win so i thought that
was actually very interesting
you make some very good points and
siobhan you made that point earlier as
well that one of the dangers here
for republicans is weakening the
electoral college hence has been
evacuated others sheltering in place
attempted coup in progress there is a
they are they are literally attempting a
coup
there is a legislative coup attempt and
there is a physical coup attempt that is
taking place
absolute chaos mike pence has been
evacuated from the senate for his own
safety as protesters now are
trying to and it i can't tell but has
this door been breached
i'm unable to see here but it appears as
though the door may have been breached
these are some of the most
anti-democratic
violent attempts we've seen to overturn
an election it it
okay this door the door is uh it's a the
door has not been breached
it still looks intact mike pence the
vice president has been evacuated from
the senate chamber
because his own supporters are acting
so erratically now how is no one being
arrested
shouldn't all of these people be
arrested at this point
are they waiting because they're calling
in uh
national guard is it that that what what
exactly is the explanation as to what is
going on here
this is this is the worst of what we
imagined could happen
most of it has already happened
most of it has has already happened and
the next several hours
are going to uh tell us which which
direction this is going to go but mike
pence
has been evacuated from the senate
let's listen
now is secret service taking pelosi out
as well is that what's happening
without objection the chair declares the
house in recess pursuant to clause 12b
of rule one
wow so the house is now in recess as
well
the house has gone into recess we are
learning on capitol hill from following
congressional reports up there
from the reporters that are in the
chamber and both the house and the
senate
uh manual raju of cnn is reporting that
the capital is now oh my god
amid a tense situation with
demonstrators outside the building
according to capital cops
one of their producers ted barrett tried
to leave the building couldn't because
cops said the building is
on lockdown people are being ordered to
stay inside
their offices now the house has gone
into recess the senate
has also gone into a recess subject to
call of the chair
wow we on to on twitter
molly hooper who covers capitol hill
saying that protesters are in the
building that was
overheard caught off mike while senator
lankford in the senate
was speaking shortly after then chuck
grassley
gaveled the senate out subject to the
call of the chair
so the u.s capitol locks down with
lawmakers inside
as the trump supporters outside have
breached the capital steps according to
cnn
we are a joke and we've all also uh saw
reports
that reporters were told that if they
enter
if if these protesters enter the capitol
building that the press would be ushered
into
their respective chambers the house and
the senate and the wow
would be locked obviously a lot unknown
right now and
watching this as it all unfolds
earlier uh do you guys understand what's
going on right now
as protesters enter can you get videos
oh my god protesters are in um so we
don't know the protesters are not
leaving they seem to be giving each
other more space
they have stopped trying to open the
glass
there is no more banging but i don't see
capitol police here
at this location where
where's the military of the senate
doorkeepers
the capitol police have asked others to
exit but there's no capital police in my
position
at this time they seem to have moved
away from this area
it now looks like the crowd is again
raising in hostility there are more
pushes at the door judy
uh this is a real test oh my god
they need they need them we need the
military right
how you need the military am i right can
someone gut check me here
into this building just extraordinary
what lisa desjardins is describing she
is located right above
as she says on a balcony inside the
capitol building on the house side
looking down at protesters breaking the
glass
attempting to break into the capitol
building and lisa
if you can still hear me is there you
say the capitol police
um are moving away does that mean
there's no security on the inside i know
you're trying to get
uh cl stay close enough to see what's
going on but we want you to stay
safe there is not security within
the first 20 feet of this door but that
is the only part that i can see
there may be security underneath me
underneath the balcony i'm standing on
but there is no police on this level
which
which there is a staircase immediately
next to this door
where protesters could obviously come up
the staircase right away
i see a pair of police handcuffs on the
ground
that were abandoned handcuffs are on the
ground that's never good
if handcuffs are loose on the ground
something went wrong
to try and break through one of these
windows
it it's hard i don't know the details of
this blast there is at least
one pain on two windows that has
shattered
the second pain seemed to be holding up
i assume that is
some kind of highly secure maybe
bulletproof glass
but protesters continue to try and break
it open
there are more and more discussions
about the word
pipe bomb being used related to
something outside the capitol
on what's going on i am told that both
the house and the senate
have now adjourned temporarily because
of these protests
no doubt out of a concern for safety of
the members of the house and the senate
this is terrorism right is there any
other way to describe it
empty members of congress we presume
have found a place to go
to keep them safe we know the vice
president regularly has
secret service with him but we don't
know
we know that members of the house and
senate typically do not other than the
speaker of the house
perhaps go ahead he's trying to say
something there are protesters
protesters have now broken into the u.s
capitol
they're inside through this door i'm
told by a side door but i have seen
protesters at this location they're
inside moving to a different location
for the moment i will come back here if
i for the term protesters seems like the
wrong term
sure who has gotten into the building it
looks like protesters are now
perhaps some of them routing oh here's a
protester who is trying to open this
door
oh my god inside for those on the
outside he's unable to do it the door
obviously has been locked
by capital police oh my god screaming
there's a chance that
a crowd of violent coup people is about
to stream into the capitol
yelling at the protesters
telling them oh that protester has now
opened the front door of the capitol
to let his fellow protesters in
there is a single capital police officer
trying to stop this one officer
he is trying to get in between the crowd
trying to enter the u.s capitol just
one police officer trying to stop a
crowd of dozens
the door is open the door is clearly
open he is unable to stop them
they are now slowly making their way
through what is a bottleneck
a small opening in this capital door is
this what
she's referring to step back because you
can hear the shouting
i'm carefully watching the situation to
keep myself safe
there are now some and it looks like
riot police
also entering the door oh my god trump
turned on pence
around the protesters government has
fallen
the only thing helping this situation is
that the door
is just barely open wide enough for a
single person
to enter at one time there is a trump
flag
on the top of protesters trying to enter
there are protesters on
each side of the door physically
contacting police
so sorry has not come to blows but there
is pushing and shoving as police
try to bring in their fellow riot police
members and stop
trump protesters now i see one two three
four five six seven eight
now now protesters protesters are now
arriving in larger numbers into the skin
through this breach
what capitals are unable to stop them
it looks like a dozen or so maybe more
this is an ongoing battle which police
are losing
it looks like protesting police are
losing control of the capital of the
united states
a stunning set of developments are lisa
desjardins at the capitol describing the
trump
uh supporters who are gathered
pro the army is going to end up coming
out
this is about to turn into a war zone in
washington dc
today they are gathered outside are we a
failed state
the president has now denounced
his own vice president as his supporters
have
violently breached security at the u.s
capitol building demanding trump be
installed
despite losing the election
that uh there are capital
they're in the they're in look now
they're in show an id
of some sort you police have lost
control of the capitol building is
normally welcome
but but in order and with identification
and this is clearly a breach of that
they're streaming in
we don't know what their intention is um
i believe they'd be walking from the
house side to the senate side
oh hold on she's trying to say something
maybe
lisa is there on the house side of the
capitol and and i'm
lisa i'm prepared to go to you whenever
you have some additional reporting
go ahead with me can you hear me
judy yes go ahead yes yes i have some of
the protesters standing with me who have
broken in
and i'm going to do an interview over
the phone very good look at capitol
police look
sir if you don't mind you're on air with
a pbs thank you for talking with me
can you tell me your name no i can't
honestly okay tell me i know that you
just broke into the u.s capitol
that's fine tell me why you just took
this action met up with our politician
this is a this is obviously
an extreme weapon the police shot at us
first before we did anything
oh my god
did the police shoot at you today are
you personally saying you saw the police
so different
you were shot by robert today can i see
that please
i do i see it okay but tell me but you
do not think this is violent breaking
into us capital
was 1776 violent oh my god
they're out of their mind 1776
wonder what is your goal here what are
you going to do after you stop talking
with me
i got to keep exploring this building
yeah we were just looking for the
bathroom when i stumbled up there oh
they're just looking for the bathroom
okay you understand that this is
this is something that you're telling
people all over america that they should
tear down public buildings
is that a message that you want to send
if the time comes where you feel like
that's necessary it's in our
constitution that
wow we can raise up against our
government what is it that has made you
so angry and this is my last question
for you i think people don't understand
what what is it exactly
the old question was stolen from donald
trump that's the main reason most of
these people are here not me personally
but
mostly did not win the election thank
you for talking to me all right
so that is these are two of the
protesters that have now entered the u.s
capitol
um you can tell it is a mix of anger and
also frankly just being cavalier
about themselves here they come here's a
big stand
they're streaming in where is the police
where is the military lisa desjardins
they're at the capitol for
if you can't secure the u.s capitol what
can you secure
to the building we have to say broken in
because
they've not gone through normal channels
they've been
they came to washington to protest to
support president trump
and now they have gone into the capitol
which is normally a place uh which is
where entrance is regulated for safety
reasons
they're streaming in this is all
happening while the house and senate
have been
in session to consider the count of the
electoral votes
both of those sessions have now gone
into recess or temporarily adjourned
for safety reasons we don't know where
the senators and the members and the
members of the house
have gone we assume they've been
escorted somewhere to stay safe
as safe as possible we also don't know
the intent
of these uh visitors protesters
we don't know we heard the gentleman say
when the time comes to rise up against
the government
um and and in essence saying that's what
they're doing so we don't know what that
means
what their end goal here is today
whether they
plan to enter the house and senate
chambers
right now this is interesting truck via
soup i am paying attention to the super
chats
trump isn't going to send in the
military to stop his own movement
uh this is the event that trump will use
as justification for declaring martial
law
why is there no military presence this
was part of trump's plan
he was always empowering the public to
fight this for him
trump is trying to take control
wow wow if you have
just joined us uh capitol police
have lost control of the u.s capitol
building
all counting of electoral votes has been
suspended
secret service has removed vice
president mike pence from the senate
chamber for his safety
capital security have uh shut down
and locked down the house and senate
chambers
everything has stopped we got through
counting alabama
and alaska an objection on arizona
coming at about
1 10 p.m eastern time a two-hour debate
started on arizona and in the midst of
that
protesters breached the first barrier of
security at the u.s capitol building
they have been streaming into the u.s
capitol media reports are that
they don't know where police are
sometimes describing one officer
sometimes describing handcuffs left on
the ground
unclear the significance of that and
uh this is partially a group of people
these uh protesters who came over from a
trump event hours ago
apparently many of them needing to use
the bathroom now because they've been
at the trump rally and then now now they
are here
but uh this is rapidly becoming a
situation
completely out of control and i don't
know
from the standpoint of law enforcement
what is being waited for
i don't know if at some point we are
going to see military show up here
and i understand the point of trump
isn't going to deploy the military
against his own supporters
it is not just up to trump to activate
either national guard or federal
military assets that is not the only way
that it can happen
and there is the hypothesis being made
by some of the people in my audience
that this is all a pretext
on which uh to stage uh to denoun to
announce martial law
uh questions as to whether a curfew will
be announced in washington dc
to put some end to this at some point in
time
i have never experienced anything like
this i have never experienced anything
like this
the entire process of counting the
ballots typically meant to be
perfunctory has been shut down
all of these folks you see here have
physically breached
the u.s capitol let's listen we have
learned now that the
as you can see the protesters have
breached the capital they're inside
they're crossing over statuary hall
which is
separate it's the chamber that separates
the house and the senate
as you can see they've made their way
over into
the house side some of them on the house
side some on the senate side
right outside these chambers don't tell
me they're getting into the chamber
who has covered capitol hill for many
years is joining us on the phone
niels do we know how it is that they
were able to get inside the capitol
well from my vantage point away from the
hill
i i don't know exactly which
door or doors they were able to breach
but
there were clearly uh protesters
uh and and violent protesters who
uh appear to have breached at least one
of the doorways
if not multiple of the capitol building
itself
uh and and so there has been
uh there were efforts at locking down
the building but but quite frankly
it appears that the sheer number of
protesters
just overwhelmed whatever capacity
that the the capitol police had
businesses seemed almost more prepared
than police businesses
have been boarding up for days and
yet protesters were able to breach the
capital at this point in time
here they are continuing to try to push
into this door the door
at one point was open uh and it looks
like it's now been
been forced shut uh and by the way if
you're just joining us
um donald trump has now officially
turned on his own vice president
he has officially turned look at this
donald trump tweeting
um 12 minutes ago mike pence didn't have
the courage to do what should have been
done to protect our country and our
constitution
the president has turned on his own vice
president that is not going to calm
anybody down
um and we are seeing the united states
listen i don't think this the country
will fall i think this will be gotten
under control
but this is this is as turbulent as
anything
i've seen um and authorities and law
enforcement
unable to secure the capital jim schudo
okay let me get to jim schudo
twitter i'm told jim sciutto
has information for us on twitter let's
take a look
uh oh i should really be following him
jim schudow says
u.s capitol police are asking for
additional law enforcement for
assistance
including federal authorities several
suspicious devices outside the capitol
building
the word pipe bomb has also been used so
you may end up with multiple bomb squads
you may end up with multiple bomb squads
having to get involved here it's
unbelievable
uh don jr has openly denounced the
protesters
okay let's look at that now
um where can i find don
jr let's see
donald trump jr
this is wrong and not who we are be
peaceful and use your first amendment
rights but don't start acting like the
other side we have a country to save and
this doesn't help
wow now you are now even
so trump has denounced his vice
president
but don jr is denouncing the actions
of the protesters it's impossible to
even keep up
it's impossible to even keep up uh 6 p.m
curfew
has been announced in washington dc
okay that's good to know this is the
exact
thing every authoritarian around the
world wanted the end of the usa
not from without but from within
this looks like an orchestrated stunt
police numbers suspiciously small from
the outset
listen i i that that's starting to get
conspiratorial
i don't understand where where law
enforcement is
the this is i mean are they
is someone going to clean the air clear
the area
i genuinely don't understand what it is
that they expect
and and that they are waiting for here
but jim schudo says they are asking for
more law enforcement all right i
i know in the midst of this people are
getting mad at me because i'm not
thanking them
um thank you to the 33 folks
who just signed up um on
on twitch i appreciate that that puts us
at 220
and also uh thank you to the
six folks who just grabbed memberships
at joinpackman.com
it's a crazy and insane day everybody
who's been supporting i really
appreciate it i'll just mention and then
we're going to get back to this
the the best and most direct way to
support our streams
is go to joinpackman.com use the coupon
code better21 i won't spend a lot of
time on it a whole bunch of people have
done it i really do appreciate it
um and it's going to be a it's going to
be a very long day as
uh the barriers and the uh security has
been breached at the u.s capitol
um and it is absolutely
absolutely insane what we are seeing
here
um let's see if donald trump has sent
any other tweets
uh trump now also wow
so the president now realizing oh wow
wow wow
you caused this give me a break
or how about come on man
and then let's retweet that
trump casually suggesting
the fire he started be sort of
put out kinda maybe
it is it is unbelievable it is
unbelievable trump now
having to say his own this own
is there anything more humiliating than
what is going on right now
trump denouncing his own supporters
trump denouncing his own supporters uh
it is it is incredible what we are
seeing
happen today in the united states let's
listen to the latest here from judy
woodruff
to this president saying today it would
it would damage our democracy
uh forever he said if this congress were
to overturn the will of the american
people
of the voters of the courts the door is
back open
and take basically look at this the
election into their own hands and decide
uh that that this is what uh should be
but that is exactly what president trump
is asking for
uh we're watching a remarkable scene
outside the capitol we knew there would
be protests today we
had no idea it was going to reach this
level that they would be
climbing the walls climbing the
perimeter of the capitol breaching the
perimeter of the capitol going inside
the building
breaking glass and so on
it is true that we don't see widespread
acts of violence outside but clearly
there was violence for them to get into
the building
and they have overwhelmed the security
at the capitol
lisa desjardins describing how the
capitol police
made room for them to come in because
they were simply outnumbered they were
not in
anywhere near enough capitol police i
should also say that
it appears that vice president pence has
been escorted away
uh to a safe place from the senate
chamber as has the senate
uh president probably going in again
senator chuck grassley of iowa
who would be the ranking republican uh
presiding over the senate
if uh if uh the vice president were not
there i i believe
what what we're seeing in different
reports is that the two of them uh have
been
uh have been safely taken away what we
don't know
is what has happened to other members of
the senate of other members of the house
it does appear from this it is going to
take years
for the country to recover from this and
by that i mean everything i'm including
the presidency of trump but it is it is
going to take years
um lawmakers are being told they may
have to duck under their chairs for
safety
every single person that broke in should
be sent to gitmo
um do you think any of this happening
will influence republicans to change
their mind and not keep objecting
god i hope so the reason there's no law
enforcement is probably because half of
that raving mob
is law enforcement no i don't think we
have evidence i don't think we have
evidence for that
um the situation very very quickly
getting out of control in washington dc
they are now in the building
they are now in the building look at
[Applause]
this
[Applause]
they have broken in there in the
building they are occupying the u.s
capitol
and we lost the video
wow this looks like minecraft um
okay we'll have to wait to get that
feedback this one is uh from across the
street
uh okay hold on national guard on the
way
according to politico all right let's
look for that
um politico
let's see here mike
pence ushered out congress paused
certification after a breach
tear gas used in the rotunda members
told to get gas masks
from under their seats oh my goodness
this is absolutely insane
sufficient and uh once we know
but i will say the other thing i will
say is that once we have uh
better guidance on on where the members
of congress
and and the senate uh are able
uh to assemble what
we actually have ability uh in and
congress has the ability to actually
convene in alternate locations
and not even all in the capitol building
wow and so
you know if we see the house or senate
uh reconvene it is entirely possible
that
could happen at least uh in
in in terms of officially being able to
gavel out or something like that
could happen uh in an alternate location
you may remember and viewers may
remember
that that actually did happen when the
earthquake
came through the national capital region
a number of years ago and the senate
actually convened
uh briefly it was only a pro forma
session there was no business
uh but the senate has in fact uh been
able to convene off-site
uh in the not too distant um
and we're leaning from from cnn that
the vice president has been evacuated
from the capitol grounds
matt fuller uh niels lesniewski who you
know for
who reports for the huffington post he
just sent this out at 2 43 guns drawn
in the chamber john bresnahan who
reports for punchbowl news now
um he sent out a tweet about two minutes
ago crowd now trying to break down doors
into the house chamber oh my god we
don't
we can't see what's going on they've put
masks on both the house and the senate
oh my god look at this ruben gallego who
i just interviewed
is instructing people to breathe slowly
with gas masks on
they're slamming on the door everyone
has gas masks i can see flashes
the chaplain is praying as protesters
have reached the doors we have people
slamming the doors
they've dispersed tear gas in the
rotunda telling members to put on gas
masks
stephen cohen says republicans need to
call trump and tell him to call off the
protesters huge commotion individuals
have reached the capitol building
wow this is happening so quickly
someone is continuing to try to talk to
protesters this is not the way to do it
mark wayne mullen is trying to talk to
the protesters through broken glass
another big band i assume that means a
band of pro
i don't think there's like a big band
like a jazz band playing i can't i don't
know
that's weird uh okay we are now inside
the chamber
inside the chamber i'm sorry not the
chamber inside the building not the
[Applause]
chamber
when's the last time the u.s saw unrest
like this where where the cat where a
building
of this stature is breached can our
historians tell me what what's the
reference point for this
[Applause]
60s
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
are they pushing out now or are they
trying to get into the senate chamber
okay i'm getting reports of shots fired
shots fired dc
latest shots fired into the u.s house
chamber
shots fired into the u.s house chamber
shots fired at the capitol building
shots fired into the chamber absolute
chaos
shots fired
we are having multiple reports of shots
fired in the capitol building
shots fired in the capitol building now
being widely reported
uh let's listen eric watson from
bloomberg
uh he he just sent a note through that
there's an armed
standoff uh at the house front
oh my god and there are guns drawn
uh with someone attempting to reach and
now there's
there are so this is continued to be
a uh developing situation and at this
point i think that the immediate the
immediate concern
is with the uh use of weapons and
and and sort of this being beyond
a peaceful protest we left that point a
long time ago
oh my god we're just continuing to see
all right let's get back to pbs
we're hearing some sort of alarm go off
elisa if you're there we'll stay with
you we do want you to stay safe oh my
god um
lisa can you tell whether they've been
able to get close to
go ahead lisa
yeah capital police are now on this
floor
they are now working to secure this
floor
protesters to go on the crowd
yeah we're gonna we're gonna have my
presidential
all right we're hearing
shouts in the background lisa we want
you to stay safe we're going to
come away for just a moment until we can
understand
a little more about what's going on
trying to understand whether they've
been able to get into the house of
chambers and of course knowing whether
the mem
go ahead lisa go ahead
the police have told me to stay down and
that's what i'm doing oh my god
and i also don't want to show a video
this area of the capital is an area that
is
usually prohibited from showing video
that's why i've been selected in
shooting video not that the capital is
operating under any sort of rules at the
moment
i want to try and be respectful while
reporting this extraordinary moment in
american history
the police do see the police have gained
control for the moment
of this quarter of the capital i no
longer hear
protesters chanting beneath me in
statuary hall
where they have been but i do hear
shouting as police
seem to one by one be taking
down the protesters telling them to get
on the ground
trying to control the situation
all right lisa we're gonna let you get
to a safe place
and now they're letting her move police
attempt to clear the protesters out oh
my god guns drawn
oh my god look at this look at what's
happening
we saw they have protesters they have
long guns
pointed at protesters
[Music]
they are evacuating the people who are
still in the chamber
i am in a call with members of congress
it's it's an
insurrection coup attempt you are
evacuating at this point
uh that portion the capital is under
control i don't have
what's this guy wearing back here by the
way i've never seen that before what is
that
gas masks oh it's a gas mask perhaps
for tear gas uh
this is holy large number of members of
congress that i'm walking out
the door with now i just can't tell you
um everyone is being calm this woman's a
hero by the way
she has not interrupted her broadcast
for like an hour
it will be hard to believe the actions
that we are being forced to take right
now
yeah heart hard to believe we want you
to stay safe while you're coming down
the stairs lisa we do see house members
we saw one as you said
with the gas mask on as you described it
and
we're watching other members trying to
get to a place of safety while the
police try to evacuate appear
apparently trying to evacuate these
protesters who are trying to
uh who are uh moving into and
and taking over some parts of the
capital
lisa they're not there sorry they're
moving us into their looks like i'm
moving it into a basement
i'm not sure what the ultimate
destination is here um some kind of
secure space
uh in the center underground of the
capital at this point so i don't know if
my signal will
will stay up but i will try and keep in
touch with you guys as much as i can
i have to take out this is probably the
safest place i can be i'm with members
of congress
and capital blue composers hello i'm
congressman
well more than anything we want you to
stay safe and of course we want all the
you know everyone there to stay safe as
safe as possible it looks like lisa's
now
been been required been forced to move
to another
another location we are um this is our
eyes and ears at the capitol lisa
desjardins
had been reporting on the debate
inside the senate in the house is now
joining members of congress in
evacuating uh
the capitol uh ordered by police to
leave
so that they can try to get the
protesters out of the building
apparently that's
what we believe is going on uh lisa's
keeping that camera with her that's
what's giving us access
to what you see in the underground
or at least in the lower floor lower
levels of the capitol
but you see people moving quickly and we
did see uniformed
officers earlier armed as they were
shouting and attempting to get the
protesters
to move um unprecedented
uh historic uh disgusting too
tragic when we think about the united
states capital we think about
the debates that go on in the committee
rooms and on the floor
this is not what we are used to seeing
at the united states capital
but here we are january the 6th 2021
we have a president protesting an
election result and
and his millions of followers thousands
of whom have shown up in washington
today
to reach the u.s capitol to go inside
to um to what end we're not clear
other than they want a different result
will anyone try to blame antifa for this
do you think anyone would be that stupid
and brazen are we going to see that or
or or is that
do we know that that's not going to be
the case because trump has also
said be peaceful and don jr has said be
peaceful and so on and so forth or do
they know that they can't do that in
this case uh
if if you are somebody who works in the
capital so there's also
the challenge of trying to figure out
how to get out of here
uh you know whether on by foot or by car
if if the capital itself is on lockdown
scott wong talk about the
the protesters even getting
onto the capital steps of the u.s
capitol
where as you know if you're up there
you're not
lawmakers are the only ones allowed on
those steps
it it really is one of the most secure
buildings
in the country there are people guarding
the building at all times i i want to
tell you guys something
there are other countries where
this type of thing happens more
frequently
than in the united states and very often
the culmination
is that trump would have to flee the
country
now this is this is different this is
the united states
and this type of thing doesn't usually
happen and presidents don't usually flee
the country
but we are like in a paradigm
that is i i i
i i it's essentially beyond words it's
essentially beyond words
what uh what what we are seeing right
now uh oh let's
let's hear from yamiche alcindor see
what she knows are you there
i didn't hear you judy essentially yes
we are seeing
the really the consequences of the
president of the united states
lying and telling millions and millions
of americans that an election was stolen
from him
if this was happening in any other
country critics say we would call this a
coup we would call it an attempt
of course over the government that
protester said he was thinking about
1776 when he told
lisa that he broke into the capital and
the president now is saying support our
police
support the capitol police but it really
is obvious here that the president
had been urged by fellow republicans at
times to condemn violence to condemn
people
gathering today in in washington d.c and
he chose not to do that instead he chose
to give an hour um long sleep more than
an hour long speech
saying again false oh my god and really
getting people they breached the look at
this elevators down
from the senate gallery look at this to
avoid protesters one thing you'll know
if you've covered the u.s capitol for
any period of time is that there
are a huge number of of back
back hallways and hidden they made it to
the speaker's
chair of these buildings so it appears
that that
is what u.s capitol police
did escorting senators out of the senate
chamber in order to keep them safe i
have been texting with one of those
senators and
asked are you and everyone around you
safe and
uninjured and he responded yes he said
capitol police first secured the senate
when the capitol was breached
and then evacuated us i'm told that
there are pictures
of uh guns drawn in the chamber let's
see if i can find
some here um oh wait hold on
photos yep look at this
look at this oh my god
that is that is the house of
representatives
here's that protester who has broken in
yelling trump won the election this
appears to be
tear gas in the hallway
oh my god now people are going crazy
texting me about what's happening
um wow
wow this is this is absolutely un
so that we're i we're we're these are
terrorists okay i i am i don't even know
why i'm calling them protesters
we're talking about terrorists here
terrorists are have have breached
and uh there's really no other way to
describe it we have a gun
guns drawn situation um this is uh
absolutely absolutely oh okay we have
lisa back the realm of reality
does this feel like for you she turned
to me judy and she said
i came to this country from guatemala a
third world country
i came here to get away from this kind
of threat
to government and she just shook her
head
you know i think right now the capitol
police do seem to be
bit by bit trying to tackle goals the
first of which clearly was to get
members of congress and people inside
the capital to safety
and it looks like that is happening now
lisa have you seen any members who are
embracing these protesters supporting
them because we know a number of them
are supporting the idea of objecting to
the electoral results
you know i am looking i do not see
any members who i know to be objectors
in this crowd i did speak earlier today
to uh representative joe wilson of south
carolina
this was after the first building after
the first place
it's a little loud right now because uh
people are being told where they're
supposed to go and where they can go uh
but
representative wilson is one of the
objectors and i and this was when one of
the buildings had been breached
and i said had you heard about this what
do you think about this and he told me
he just hadn't heard about it yet he had
he had no comment
on it at all but i am very eager to hear
what
members of congress uh supported
the objections say about this obviously
none of them want violence none of them
want this breach to have happened
it'll be very interesting to see what
their reaction is whether they are
embracing what these protesters are
doing or whether they're going to speak
up and say they've gone too far
because essentially their actions are
what has
brought these protesters to washington
and to the capitol
so uh it will be interesting to see the
explanations
uh that we hear but what the protesters
have done
is they've managed to put a halt to what
was supposed to be
of the constitutional wow requirement
that
wow widespread reports that the defense
department
is denying a request
by d.c officials to deploy the national
guard
uh wow
wow which raises questions
about how much of this is politically
advantageous for who knows who
for who knows who um this is
uh this this is a this is a dark day for
the united states
um i appreciate i appreciate the uh
continued
support um 37 more people
have just grabbed twitch subscriptions i
i really do appreciate that and um
17 more people have grabbed website
memberships which i i really do
appreciate it we are all riveted to what
is going on here
um a breach at the u.s capitol i'm gonna
do a full reset in about five minutes
and catch everybody up but
uh we've never done anything i mean
listen this this is
the the country feels like it's on the
brink and that's why we have 120
000 uh people watching right now across
our platforms this is
absolutely absolutely and utterly insane
um let's listen i'm gonna step away and
just take a five refill my water and do
a bathroom break
and then i'll reset everything that is
going on for everybody progress and we
know as we reported a few moments ago
there
there have now been uh more armed
law enforcement have been called into
the capital area so there will be
we presume attempts made to clear the
capital of the protesters we saw some of
that
lisa was right there inside the capitol
a few minutes ago when
we saw law enforcement armed law
enforcement
trying to get protesters out
but that's going to take some time to do
we don't know the course that this is
going to take
this is all unfolded in a very uh
unplanned
at least to us unplanned unknown manner
and we are following it just as you are
as you're watching this
we weren't sure where we knew there were
protests we did not know it was going to
lead to this
and so um we we continue to watch but
for the time being
the business of the congress called for
in the constitution
to count the electoral votes has stopped
that's going to have to continue at some
point
after the the capital is made safe
and lisa as far as we know they haven't
even been able to
move on past the state of arizona so
they've got another 47 states to go plus
the district of columbia
that's right we we were expecting today
something
like 12 hours devoted to
the electoral process and to finishing
the 2020 election
right now it is unclear that that could
possibly continue today i'd be
very surprised if it can continue
anytime soon obviously with those
pictures
it's very helpful to see the pictures
that you're showing of the front steps
because here inside the capitol
we're very blind as to how many
protesters we're talking about
uh where are they are they still in the
capital steps so um that's very good
information for me and for those of us
here to see that the protesters are
still there
and and and still i i'm assuming perhaps
threatening or able to get into the
capital in some form
uh so this tells me that there's a very
long timeline ahead
before bringing back this electoral
process
i want to also say a quick word about
capital police you know i've been a
capitol hill reporter i've had the
privilege to be here for
a long time and they are some of the
hardest working people
completely devoted to their craft and
and they have lately been working there
like because of the protesters many of
them because of
the last year of upheaval in american
politics
unsung untalked about capitol police
have been working long hours
they have been devoted to their cause
they have been at their
at their stance for this building
obviously there will be a lot to talk
about
how capital police handle this incident
why this happened
but i just want to put in a word for
them because i know these guys and women
uh and
they're very dedicated servants all
right we are back i'm glad you did that
lisa because
let's uh let's let's just do a reset
because this is
we're now two more than two hours in um
i should do a reset because at this
point a lot of the people that are
watching
don't know how all of this started uh
welcome
welcome back uh thanks for being here if
you are
uh if you are are continuing to be here
um we have um
i mean where do you start today was the
day on which we were scheduled
to simply simply count the electoral
votes that were cast on december
14th um we knew that there would be oh
my god look at this
we knew that there would be some
objections and indeed after the
acceptance of the alaska vote
of the alabama vote and the alaska vote
there was an objection around arizona
and at that point in time the house and
senate separated and they were going to
debate for two hours
the merits of their objection to
counting the arizona votes
uh and look at what these people are
doing we're deal we are dealing really
with uh
this is this is uh i mean just look at
what's going on
during that two-hour debate over arizona
and remember we were already expecting
this to go late into the night because
there were going to be objections in six
different states
during the arizona debate
protesters coming from a trump rally
just a few blocks away started
attempting to breach the outer line
of law enforcement at the u.s capitol
building
and when it became clear that police may
be outnumbered
they um uh escorted out
mike pence secret service escorted out
mike pence and by the way moderators
i see people in the chat attacking me
saying that this is no big deal
um if they're serious i know some people
are kidding if they're serious we gotta
we gotta get them out okay we're not
gonna do that
um so then they actually breached the
capitol building
and the senate and house chambers were
locked down
uh there were guns drawn in the chamber
there were uh there was tear gas
inside the building and everything has
been completely interrupted
this is a situation unlike any i've ever
covered
donald trump then on top of everything
fully denounced his own vice president i
mean this this is what we call
a fall of government government is
falling
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what would what should have been done
the president has denounced his own vice
president okay
and now we are in a situation where a 6
pm curfew has been put in place in
washington dc
uh there has been a request made that
the national guard be deployed
which we are told so far the defense
department is denying
denying the request and that is where we
are right now it
uh this is uh it feels like the
potential collapse
of the united states it absolutely feels
that way
people talking about bomb bomb checks
and all these different things via via
super chat
there were reports of uh explosions we
don't yet know
i mean it's we have reports of shots
fired and all of these different things
um let me just see if we can get to it
twitter seems to be the place where
we're learning most quickly what's going
on
anna says this is insane the u.s capitol
is on lockdown
a mob marching behind a confederate flag
stormed the u.s capitol look at this
[Music]
he should be impeached and removed
tomorrow
the the a lot of people talking about
impeachment
and um i mean listen
these are the people that don junior
just denounced an
hour ago don jr tweeted promoting the
people
that he just denounced minutes ago
this is wrong and not who we are
the they are incoherent my friends they
are completely
and utterly incoherent let's get the
latest update
you're the protesters but it is it is a
stark split screen
stream for that president trump is
really enjoying in some ways this calm
while so much is happening someone was
shot inside the cap
a woman was shot inside the capitol did
you hear that sorry i just saw a report
about someone being shot and that's not
confirmed so i want to
make that clear but it was startling uh
to see
uh just now yamiche let me a woman was
shot
inside the capitol well judy that's
disturbing if if true and and
what what you hear here is that the
president is watching all this unfold
allies of the president are condemning
this right there but the president is
not at this point having to reap some of
the chaos
that he sowed he is sitting here um
armed in a bubble of security
oh my god is now um completely breached
while the capital is having to deal with
the look at this this is benji starlin i
was in the speakers oh wait i was in the
speaker's lobby once oh no sorry that
that's not that's not the story of what
happened right now
uh just saw a woman covered in blood
removed from the capitol building on a
stretcher she appears to have been shot
multiple reports now that a woman has
indeed been shot in the capitol building
uh this appears to be the woman she was
shot reportedly
inside the capitol building
um wow
wow cell phone video of a woman
shot in the neck just moments ago this
reportedly just in the last
five to ten minutes a woman has been
shot inside the capitol
that is absolutely unbelievable the
american people is
in this moment choosing not to do that
well the condemning the violence uh and
asking people to respect
the police but as you say only after
weeks and weeks
days and days months and months of
questioning the election result and
calling on people to protest in any form
i want to say we now i now am seeing a
report a dc paramedic source
is uh saying that one person was shot
inside the capitol
we don't have that confirmed but we are
certainly looking into it there are
other news reports right now
this one from nbc is saying there's
video of protesters
inside the senate chamber rummaging
through senators desks
so we are these are oh my god i'll be
following up on in our attempt
to to understand what's going on and can
you imagine
uh whether someone has been shot we did
see when lisa
desjardins was reporting from inside the
capitol where she was following the
protesters trying to understand
where they were and where they were
going you could see that police were
armed we didn't hear any shots
while lisa was reporting but this latest
information is that
someone has been shot so again not
confirmed
but we are widely reported find out uh
uh where things stand let's go to our
amna nawaz who has been reporting from
just outside the capitol she's on this
is like
nothing we have seen a very
that's a very safe location it is very
highly
secured and so when the capitol ends
lockdown that is
where we headed the doors were
barricaded etc
it became clear at one point that the
lawmakers who
were seated in the chamber itself
not no longer conducting business
business ended when the lockdown began
they were told to evacuate the chamber
which was
thought to be the safest place for them
to be
that was a crush towards the doors as
everyone tried to get out of there
we reporters along with uh
senators themselves staff etc were then
hustled
um to i'm not going to share my location
for security reasons um of where we now
are um wow
trump now trying to put out the fire he
started i am
asking for everyone at the u.s capitol
to remain peaceful
no violence remember we are the party of
law and order respect the law
wow wow
that is unbelievable that's not what i
meant to do
today's violence is your legacy
wow
look at the audacity
it is unbelievable it is absolutely
and completely unbelievable trump's
supporting flags
there's a state by state flag and
there's also this chant we hear again
and again from people saying
this is our house you work for us and
this
is one of the messages that they were
very intent on getting out
to those members of congress and to
those senators which is that
this is not something that they want to
see happen they believe that those
members work for them this is their
house
and that they want to see the election
stopped in its tracks right now
so judy right now we're keeping an eye
on this crowd as i said
it's sort of just a standoff in this
moment it's also unclear i should say if
president trump's tweet calling for calm
has made it to the crowd the chanting
continues the yelling continues
at times music playing continues it's a
very surreal scene
and you cannot see i'm thinking it'll
probably take more than a few more hours
to finish counting the ballots on
account of this
press corps so these are people from
around the world who have come here
to report on this part of the american
electoral process
and i heard yamiche mentioning earlier
as well i myself as someone who's
covered elections around the world for
years
finding this to be a very surreal scene
that here in america
at the end of this presidential election
which should be towards the end of this
presidential election
this is where we find ourselves with
this kind of scene and thousands of
protesters
calling for the process to start that
message is being now broadcast out to
the rest of the world which is watching
very closely to see how this ends judy
nawaz at the capitol and you're
absolutely right surreal
and beyond disturbing we can report
that kevin mccarthy who's the ranking
republican
in the house of representatives is
saying that someone was shot
the newshour is able to report from a
source
we find reliable that someone was shot
in the chest
inside the capitol it was not a
uniformed officer so we can assume
it was a protester but we don't know
there's another report that i read that
cpr was being administered to this
person we're waiting
for more information but clearly events
have taken a
very very dark turn uh at the united
states capitol where supporters of
president trump
have broken into the capitol have
basically
have now have their run of the building
from one end to the other and
uh are being pursued by uh security
and asked to leave and uh we now know as
we say and i'll repeat it's nice they're
being asked to confirm that someone was
shot kevin mccarthy the senate
republican leader i'm sorry the house
republican leader saying
yes someone was shot and our own
information at the newshour someone was
shot in the chest
and another report that so it's possible
two people were shot because there was a
report about someone shot in the neck we
we
just don't know whether the location of
the injury was
wrong or whether there's two people
again urging calm i don't have the
the text of exactly here it is this is
another
tweet from the president just in the
last minute or so
the president asked quote everyone at
the capitol to quote remain
peaceful quote no violence exclamation
point
remember we are the party of law and
order
end quote and again these are supporters
of the president
who are uh behind what you're seeing
in all these pictures and um and this is
the president asking his own people
uh to be calm a little too late at the
capitol what are you learning lisa
yeah you know i just was uh speaking to
another member of congress
representative mark de sonier uh he's a
newshour watcher
and i think this just speaks to the very
strange
uh mood that we're in you know as i told
you i saw some
people with tears in their eye fear on
their face
uh representative sonya said i love your
cat
so i wanna i just wanna convey that
inside the capitol
you know there there is some calm there
are some people who are trying to
keep spirits high like he is obviously
my
cat is way more famous than i am so that
was an appropriate remark
um but it's just more to the mood here i
think we are in an in between time
where people don't know what to feel um
people
are mostly texting their loved ones
saying hey i'm fine
everything's okay i know you're seeing
some alarming things on television
and then i see them text and turn to
each other and say
what's happening i can't believe what is
happening right now
so it is a moment of so there's a new
report that it may actually be
three people who have been shot
nobody lisa wants to believe that this
has happened but obviously it has
happened we now have
reports that a person was shot inside
the capitol um
presumably a protester we're told it's
not law enforcement
so we're trying to get more information
and i know you lisa and
the rest of our team will be trying to
get that information as soon as we can
but even before we heard that someone
had been shot
the pictures the scene this is an
interesting point from
trey who says well donnie did tell his
cultists to stand
by i guess this is what happens when
they jump into action
are the electoral college votes secure
yeah they were rushed out at the very
very beginning of this um
it was one of the first things that
happened they took those they took the
ballots out
um very very very early and there are
conflicting reports right now
as far as the national guard clearly
clearly the military is needed here
um and there are conflicting reports
about
whether uh hold on where did i have that
um i had breaking a source tells me the
defense department has just denied
a request by dc officials to deploy the
national guard
but at the same time we are there are
others
other reports saying the national guard
is on the way
uh the d.c mayor did announce a 12-hour
curfew is starting at 6 p.m
um and uh we are we are sort of waiting
on the national guard two sources
familiar tell me that speaker pelosi and
mayor bowser have asked for the national
guard to come to capitol hill to clear
rioters
one of those sources says dod has not
yet approved change of mission
for the dc guard so clearly they need
that the it's very clear that the
national guard is needed here
um we continue to see this crowd that
has breached the u.s capitol
and they are inside uh there are just
there's a random smattering of officers
here and there and as you can see it's
starting to see as though
there is a little bit heavier of a law
enforcement presence they've at least
kind of created a
perimeter here and maybe they're going
to start escorting some of these people
out let's listen briefly and see what
the tone is
[Applause]
i mean at a certain point if you're law
enforcement and you know the limitations
of what the number of people you have
can do
i think you do what they are doing which
is to the extent that you're not at risk
you
just try to create a perimeter and and
they wait for more people to show up i
don't know and as you can see there are
more officers starting to enter um
and i mean at some point it's just a
matter of the numbers if you if you
don't have the numbers you don't have
the numbers
um and conflicting reports about if
when or whether the national guard is on
the way but as of right now there are
just too
few people too few people um
to move a crowd this big and they have
breached the senate chamber they've
reached the house chamber
it's it's absolutely unbelievable what's
going on here
and really the questions now are how
long is this going to be allowed
to go on let's see if judy woodruff has
more news silence
we're waiting to find out more about the
individual who was shot
inside the capitol i want to go back to
the two gentlemen who are
veterans of working on capitol hill john
hart who worked for republican
tom coburn democrat danny weiss worked
for house speaker
nancy pelosi as her chief of staff danny
i didn't get a chance to come to you
a few minutes ago but i have to keep
asking the two of you
what do you make of this as someone who
knows that building
and knows the work that goes on inside
there day after day
it's extremely disheartening uh and and
it's scary
uh you know one of the there are a few
things i've been thinking about one is
um it's really unbelievable that the
capitol police
appear to have been uh unprepared
yes um there have been a number of
occasions where the capitol police have
been significantly dressed down
for failing to have proper procedures
and then they
take better procedures and again members
of congress are dependent on the capitol
police
and the sergeant-at-arms for their
security uh it's difficult to
second-guess the police
however after 9 11 there was a
significant
uh dressing down of the police because
there was no evacuation
uh process in place there were as i said
earlier
police with guns running down the
hallway knocking on your door yelling at
you
to run and that was uh considered to be
extremely inappropriate
way to get people safely evacuated
the next thing that's going to happen is
that you know first of all
we don't know how the rest of the day is
going to unfold
and in order for congress to resume its
work
the entire capitol building will have to
be cleared
and sweeped you don't know what anyone
has brought into the building at this
point
you don't know if anyone has found a
place to hide in the building and the
police know that
and they know that it's going to take
some time to restore the building
and make sure that it's complete one of
the things that i think is really
important here
and um i i'm interested in
hearing from people in the chat is they
should continue and finish the count
today
because the worst thing would be i mean
listen arrest everybody that you can
you've got to get this under control
curfew etc
you can't let them to actually delay
the inevitable counting of the legal
vote it's
very important in terms of precedent
it's very important in
i mean listen they've delayed it for a
few hours but you you've got to finish
the count
and it's extraordinarily important and
if these republicans if these
republicans had any morality they would
say
this wasn't ever actually going to
prevent trump from becoming the
president
i'm sorry prevent biden from becoming
the president
because of what happened we're going to
skip the rest of our objections we made
our arizona objection
and i think it is extremely important
that they actually just get the count
done
and show that even this as unprepared as
capital police were
they have to they have to finish the
count in the building earlier are now
going to be reinforced if they haven't
already
by the national guard we know that
muriel bowser the mayor
d.c had asked the national guard to
reinforce
d.c police anticipating these protests
today that the
president trump had called for right he
called for his supporters to show up in
washington
um but clearly there was no
uh anticipation that this would happen
or surely there would have been more
security that would have prevented the
protesters from
from getting a lot of people making
really really good points yes there is
an alternate location where they can
conduct business from they talked about
that earlier
i they are absolutely able to do that um
i see people saying
wouldn't you need to completely sweep
the building before you can let people
back in
of course yeah this building is not
going to be usable um
certainly for some period of time
because uh
that you need to go through everything
who knows if a pipe bomb was left behind
or whatever
everybody's absolutely correct here know
that
that it was not someone in law
enforcement so
we are waiting for more information
about that and about whether that's the
only
shooting incident that's the only one
we've seen reported
so far the other thing we want to share
with you is that joe biden who had been
scheduled to make
a statement today about the american
economy
um because because here we are now just
15
days away from his becoming president of
the united states
and you can see this is the picture in
wilmington delaware
uh where he has been speaking to the
american people to the press
uh in recent days he'll be speaking just
in a matter of minutes
okay that's good uh just maybe 3 30
eastern time
we're going to go to that uh so
hopefully we'll see
you know what some what what sort of
calming influence joe biden can have i
think that that's very
very important to see as the chaos just
will not stop you still have a crowd of
people
inside the capitol building they've
breached it people scale look at this
people scaling fences i mean
why do you need to get up there what's
up there that you need to get to
it it's it's just the absolute worst of
humanity
and uh as you can see many people with
no masks it's just this this is just the
worst
um some some of the and yeah and it
looks like there's just stairs maybe
they're just climbing for fun
with a rope i don't i don't really
understand that um
but there's a lot wrong a lot wrong with
a lot of these people
just real quick i i won't i won't take
too much time but there have been people
who have been supporting and i really
appreciate that
i do want to say thanks to the um 45
additional twitch subscribers 45 people
which puts us at 325 many of those
twitch prime
i really appreciate that and then also
on our website
um another 16 which
uh was that 341 i think that my math is
is remaining sort of okay and uh i see a
couple people saying they're having
trouble with the coupon code the coupon
code's working fine tons of people are
using it
it's better 21 it's all lowercase and
you can use it
on your choice of memberships at
joinpackman.com
uh we do have um about 130 000 people
with us today uh no 122 000 people with
us right now
and i really appreciate that we're all
trying to figure out what's going on
here
and um at this point i think at this
point uh moderators
uh let let's let there's a lot of stuff
starting to happen
um in the chat that we need to deal with
and i see that you guys are handling it
as best you can but we're getting uh
we're getting barraged by a lot of
really horrible things
um but what you can do to fight them is
just make sure you're following
if you're watching on twitch or
subscribed if you're watching on youtube
okay let's listen again to lisa
desjardins as we await a statement from
joe biden
honey there's the sign for dunkin donuts
uh
usually a gathering point for people to
make contacts and have lunch
and what you see behind me instead this
is where people are sheltering
several journalists are here many
staffers
you can see if you walk over here with
me a lot of folks
have been watching there's a single
television
here a lot of folks here in the basement
of the capitol eager for news on the
outside
because we can't go outside right now
trying to figure out what the situation
is
you can see these folks we can't move to
the other room of the cafeteria
they have separated the rooms you can
also see
right here my guess
is that down in the basement there her
service isn't that great the
the problem is with her video it's not
with pbs or hours
here inside their own workplace
unable to leave the dunkin donuts area
and i think these are this is a scene of
more people than most places in the
capital but this is what's happening
all across the capitol people in offices
not leaving their space not sure when
they can leave their space
staying calm but unsure how long this is
going to last
remarkable that they're staying calmly
under under the circumstances
um and no doubt members of congress uh
are
assuming that once the situation or once
the building is cleared
that at some point there's gonna be a
resumption of the
counting of the electoral votes we don't
know whether that can take place today
tonight whenever but
presumably they want to stay close by uh
for for the time for the moment when
that can resume
um so we're waiting for more we are told
that speaker pelosi called for the
national guard
to reinforce i'm getting a ton of
messages from people trying to get
information to me i'm just triaging some
of it and i'll let you guys know i
i'm not being rude i'm just trying to
follow up and seeing what i want to
communicate to everybody right now he is
reporting that the joint staff that's
uh the the military the uniformed uh
head of the military telling him off the
record well
sorry i'm not supposed to report this
it's off the record but um
in essence we're waiting to find out
more about
whether um uh the national guard will be
called in
um uh at the capitol um and so
we we're looking at uh different reports
from different media
um if that if the national guard is
going to come in
uh are the protesters going to go
willingly how long can it take the
national guard to get there
quite frankly i mean you'd think that
they could get there in 30 minutes
and we've been waiting now for some time
to fuss and say i'm not going
what will happen we know that at least
one of them has been
shot in the chest waiting to find out
uh the the uh the outcome there
you know what is uh what's the condition
of that person
um now i'm i'm reading by one of this is
from one of our colleagues
courtney norris who says that a
supporter of president trump one of the
protesters is sitting inside the office
of speaker pelosi
um carrying on his protest inside the
capitol
that may very well be an area
very well be an area that the public can
be invited into people do are received
in the offices of the members of
congress i'm seeing another
report now in essence that a woman
is being is seen receiving first aid
due to a gunshot injury to her neck
after being shot
inside the capitol this is another news
source
we will try to again confirm
exactly what happened so this is a cnn
feed that we have here
and as you can see members of congress
told to shelter in place and it's just
complete and total chaos if you do want
chicken and fries though there does seem
to be a little booth available there
um in the bottom left of the screen and
uh anyone's guess whether it's a you
know a corn flake crust on the chicken
tenders or what
what that is but probably not the time
for that if i were there i don't know
that i'm getting tenders at this point
in time
we are standing by i guess for the
national guard to arrive and we're also
standing by for
president-elect joe biden it does look
like there is a show of force here
arriving and this seems to be
this seems to be a strong contingent of
troops there that are arriving
and troops i'm using the term loosely
it's not clear that they're that they're
military
it seems as though they've
re-established some kind of a perimeter
here and that
hopefully they're going to be able to
get this under control
in relatively short order there has also
been a curfew
announced for washington dc for 6 pm now
in the meantime i'm also getting reports
that the kansas and georgia state houses
are at risk of
also being breached or or may have
already been breached
kansas and georgia georgia we know the
political significance of kansas i don't
know
kansas i'm not so sure of um but we're
starting to see
the it's it appears as though we're
starting to see the arrival
maybe of additional um
elements of law enforcement elements of
law enforcement
um and i'm told that police right now
are in the process of forcing this group
out let's listen a little bit that
now we do seem to be seeing more police
than protesters for the first time in a
while
and it seems they are forcing people out
one of the last people left in here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the governor of virginia is sending the
virginia national guard in 200 virginia
state troopers that seems like it will
be useful
[Applause]
okay so police at least in this area of
the capital reestablishing some control
some control and getting the crowd moved
out and
um let's see how quickly if and when
some of these additional resources show
up they can get things under control
today was a mere to be a mere formality
but then there were protests
there were objections raised by a
handful of
republican senators by over 100
around 100 republican house members
at the behest of president trump they
were asked to object
to the electoral count with no factual
basis whatsoever
of any irregularity simply an allegation
that um something went wrong we heard
uh congressman steve scalise of
louisiana hey this might be interesting
is fox news covering this let's just see
what's happening on fox news i'm curious
what their commentary is
uh yeah i'll allow ads i guess in
exchange for
being able to see this pause on this
site there we go
okay we already did that let's refresh
i'm wondering how fox news is covering
what's going on here
let's take a look
what could they possibly be saying
reportedly
shot and they said i said are you gonna
go home because the dc mayor has asked
for
a 6 p.m curfew and they aren't going to
go home
but what we see now the steady stream
you're looking at
are people that had come down they
originally were at the ellipse where we
were
where the president told them that we're
not giving this election
up and that he indeed won and now they
all went down to the capitol and a lot
of them are starting to leave starting
to stream out where we are you know i'll
tell you bill
the sign that we saw the most is
that just said trump won trump won and
when i was at
the president's speech on the ellipse
the chant we kept hearing was
fight for trump fight for trump and
clearly
it was a call to action that we've seen
unfold here in the streets and
so i do think it's a good thing that the
crowd seems to mostly be moving away
from the capital rather than towards it
but you still have these people
including one person with a no socialism
sign
of course no risk of socialism in the
united states anytime soon we know that
um they they seem to be staying and
we're going to be hearing from joe biden
soon so this could go this could go two
ways there's a curfew starting at 6 p.m
which is just a little over two hours
from now at this point
this could start to dissolve with the
curfew coming
people getting bored and quite frankly
getting hungry and having to go to the
bathroom
um and it getting maybe colder
uh you may see people start to leave
particularly as
um virginia national guard and state
troopers and others show up or
as night falls it could get even crazier
it's really it's really just
unpredictable at this point
let me see some super chats and see
what's on people's minds are they
chanting bring mike pence
yeah they were they were chanting bring
mike pence trump supporters on twitter
those look like antifa anyone can
wear put on a red trump hat yeah look at
your twitter tweet uh twitter
kaylee just said dump is sending the
national guard this is crazy okay let's
look at that
um press
secretary kaylee mckennany
at president trump's direction the
national guard is on the way
along with other federal protective
services we reiterate president trump's
call against violence and to remain
peaceful
um all right
trump is sending the
national guard to put down the prot
the violent protests he
incited all right so trump now
agrees with the national guard going in
trump agrees with the national guard and
of course there are some
very cynical folks who are saying this
is all part of trump's plan to have a
justification to declare
martial law um i don't think that that's
going to happen
i don't think that that's going to
happen mike pence i am told
is tweeting let's see what mike pence is
now saying
uh mike pence vice president mike pence
peaceful protest is the right of every
american but this attack on our capital
will not be tolerated
and those involved will be prosecuted to
the fullest extent of the law
the violence and destruction taking
place at the u.s capitol must stop
and it must stop now that's capitalized
my friends
anyone involved must respect law
enforcement officers and immediately
leave the building so they seem to know
there is no reason to keep this going
extent
of the law so yamiche i'm looking to you
this is vice president pence loyal to
president trump
who called these protesters out but now
you have the
vice president saying uh
that they will be they will be
prosecuted that's right and the vice
president's statement at this point
is more biting more pointed than
president trump's statements now
president trump
is someone who is a communications
president a reality tv president
he has called into more newsrooms than
any other president in history and right
now we have not actually heard
from the president he is watching this
from from what i'm told from the west
wing
of the white house in the security
bubble of the white house things are
very very calm here a complete
difference from what we're seeing happen
on capitol hill what we're seeing happen
in cities and states across the country
um the president here is is being urged
by both
people inside the white house as well as
people who have left the white house who
used to work for him
to say more to be more biting in this to
really condemn people and tell people to
go home
but the president hasn't done that the
white house press secretary is tweeting
much like the president
again both of them not coming to the
camera not saying in person what should
what they want to say but the white
house press secretary is saying that the
president
has pushed for the national guard to
come and help out
um there were reports at one point that
there were some hedging on whether or
not that would be something that the
president would want to do
so what we see here is the president
taking a social media in a moment
where americans are simply terrified and
i have to say judy
um the false information has
consequences the the the
conspiracy theories has consequences
yeah also we're seeing today we are
seeing the consequences
of the president's actions so uh i don't
i don't i've not heard at least at this
point
when we expect the national guard to
show up but at least for the cr
the immediate crowd that's hanging
around at the capitol
they don't seem very interested in
leaving now this group that we have on
screen here
they were successfully pushed out of the
capitol building by
law enforcement they were inside and
they have been pushed outside
and some slight very slight semblance
of reestablishing a perimeter
has has been seen now and at least these
folks have been pushed out
but who knows whether they will be able
to reestablish themselves back inside
a number of different streams let's see
again how fox news is covering this
uh the national guard is on the way as
far as storming the capital stopping the
proceeding today
one of the demonstrators i talked to
called that a victory but also said
that it went too far as far as the scene
said around here it's uh it's cold it's
brisk
people are walking around they've got
their flags at the ready
mostly people milling about and one of
the points that the demonstrators are
making
is that this is different from what we
have seen with the blm type
demonstrations because
aside from some of the things that were
broken getting into the capital
uh and disregarding the the reports now
of the woman who was shot
aside from the things that were broken
getting into the capital in terms of
doors
they say there is no vandalism taking
place oh listen to that
listen so this is for oh wow wow wow
so first of all other than
uh breaching uh and fighting with
oh and you see a large group of law
enforcement in the background other than
breaching
and and uh using the the banisters to
attack police
and breaking into the capitol and
breaking windows
and rummaging through the offices of
people
and slicing open with box cutters the
tent and look at this
broke breaking a window and going
through this is different guys than
black lives matter
because other than all of those things
it's nothing
there's nothing violent happening does
that make sense
does anybody i sound very stupid saying
that i feel very stupid saying that
um that that is pretty amazing that
that's the framing
the police generally will try to stand
down be as low profile as possible
to avoid any friction but that moment
they show up and the moment they show up
in force
the people who showed up here looking
for a fight get that fight
and you get all the bad images that get
splashed all over uh
uh you know everything from the internet
to cable news
unfortunately mike you have too much
experience on the streets watching
protests across the country
and around the world from the previous
time in the middle east
mike thank you mike tobin there the vice
president mike
pence writes on twitter peaceful protest
is the right of ever american but this
attack on our capital
will not be all right so that's on fox
news and then here's cnn
how it happened and and
he is he is culpable for this you know
uh winston churchill
said dictators ride to and fro upon
tigers
which they dare not dismount and the
tigers are getting hungry
the president sits in the white house
and the tigers are loose
uh at the capitol you know i i just let
me just say one more thing gloria
i am the son of an immigrant who fled a
country
because of scenes like this and came to
the united states because
this was a country of law this is a
country of laws and many of us share
that story
i am in tears today to see this scene
this is not an american scene and this
was not a necessary scene
and i i understand completely why it
happened
gloria i'm i'm heartbroken um
you know i spent 10 years uh
walking up and down those steps covering
capitol hill
having a great deal of respect for
the people who serve in that capital
most of the time by the way talk about
policy even with senator santorum over
there
and i watched this today and i said
that's that's my capital
that's my house that's our house
and so these are the scenes and joe
biden is going to be speaking
shortly so we are keeping an eye on that
oh they're talking to jamie raskin who's
inside
what we say but i am in a safe location
uh still
on the hill and um you know
so i i think that um all members are
safe right now as far as i know
where were you when they breached the
capitol and got inside these protesters
i don't i don't know when they actually
breached the capitol but
i do know there were repeated efforts to
uh barrel into uh the capital chamber
um and there were
yeah i was in the chamber then and there
were protesters who were trying to
ram up against the doors and they seemed
to be
roaming for for a while
were you in the chamber when this
happened yes
what was going through your mind
um well um
we experienced a terrible family tragedy
in the last week and so i had one of my
daughters with me and i had a son-in-law
with me
because we wanted to be together and i
thought i could show them the peaceful
transfer of power in the united states
of america so what was really going on
in my mind was
their safety because they were not with
me in the chamber and i just wanted to
make sure
that we could get back together and
we're all back together and we are safe
now
yeah congressman we are sorry for your
loss um
the tragedy that you experienced this
week and now
here we are um with the
capital being breached um
what were you told about security
heading into today
um i'm not the best person to ask that
just because i was
you know so distracted with our terrible
family misfortune um we were you know we
were certainly told to take care that
the proud boys in the right wing was
being encouraged to come to washington
uh by president trump um and that we
needed to
take take care take precautions and to
stay
inside the buildings as much as possible
what have you learned about and
obviously you can't share everything
with us but what have you learned about
uh what comes next
um well i don't i don't know but i'll
tell you this that every single member
that i've
spoken to is absolutely determined to
have us complete
the accounting the electoral college
votes as is
demanded of us by the 12th amendment of
the constitution and
it's being reported that pr vice
president mike pence
just unfollowed donald trump on twitter
it's being
quite widely reported and i don't know
if anybody can confirm that to me
but um in the last couple of hours we
have seen what appears to be
uh a complete and total separation of
donald trump denouncing mike pence
earlier today
and um i know it's like who cares who
follows who on twitter but if indeed you
are seeing
a vice president and a president
completely uh at odds over the fact that
the vice president isn't willing to try
to steal the election for the president
um it is it is really crazy
um he still
well there's two accounts remember guys
there's two pens accounts and there's
two trump accounts who knows
in any case what we what we do know is
that
donald trump did denounce pence
uh just moments ago mike pence didn't
have the courage
to do what should have been done to
protect
our country and our constitution
um so a president denouncing their own
their own vice president and i'm told
that
he unfollowed trump's main account
uh okay yeah that's what it's again they
each have two accounts so i'm not
surprised that there's a little bit of
confusion as to as to exactly which one
it is
more people were affected than would
have been affected a year ago
is that many of the congressional
offices have either
no staff or very little staff because of
the coronavirus
so many of people in the capital complex
like so many americans are working
remotely capital complex has some 20 000
employees that's down to a mere fraction
these days because of the coronavirus
now on the other hand
today was probably the most the most
i've seen of staff
in a year and that's because it's the
first week of congress
and it is the electoral college
certification so
fewer staff are here than usual but more
than we've seen during most of the
coronavirus
one other note judy i have seen capitol
police gathering
uh in a stairwell in the building that i
am at
they clearly are trying to figure out
their next steps they are organizing
um you know i obviously didn't speak to
them they have a job to do but i can
tell you that they are
they're organizing they are gathering in
their groups here
um i don't know what their next step are
but they're they're clearly trying to
figure that out themselves as well
yeah lisa desjardins reporting
from the capitol complex lisa's been
there for us
on the inside as our eyes and ears
lisa lisa reporting on the there are
law enforcement trying to get things
under control we know that both
the governor of virginia ralph northam
as i reported a few minutes ago said
he's sending in
the national guard from his state i now
know i can report that
from maryland the governor of maryland
larry hogan has said that maryland is
sending in
state troopers and national guard as
well
to help get the capital get the
washington d.c and get the united states
capitol
under control under a safe uh to a
position where it's safe for people
to be there i just want to share also
the new york times is reporting
maggie haberman who typically covers the
white house is reporting an explosive
device was found
at the republican national committee and
detonated
safely so that's another development
we are we are we will be following
today that's someone else
danny weiss who worked for speaker
pelosi
for several years you've been at the
capitol you have decades of experience
in the building
you've been talking to folks what are
you learning
well most members seem to be safe
staff seem to be safe they're reporting
that they're locked down
um as lisa just reported uh many of them
are working from home uh only staff that
were needed for today's procedure
uh were in the capital or or in the
house office buildings uh but you know
that they're uh
uh deeply concerned and you know they're
this is an institution okay so i've
worked there for a long time it's it's
an institution
that has done a lot of good it's an
institution that has done
a lot of bad uh i personally care about
the institution
i know a lot of members do and a lot of
staff so there are reports of people
continuing to be inside nancy pelosi's
office there are reports of videos of
let's see police protesters dc
um let's take a look at that
of uh selfies being taken between
police and so-called protesters
but it may be fine difficult to find
those right now
we will have time to see exactly what
the response was from different
elements of law enforcement to this
entire thing
and we are standing by for a joe biden
joe biden expected to speak
very very soon here in washington dc
they
still appear to be trying to breach back
in
to get back in and if you were watching
earlier um
these uh uh insurrectionists actually
did get into the capitol there are
reportedly still some inside
eventually they got this door closed and
got people
out of it um but it continues to be
an absolutely chaotic situation and we
don't really know
uh how much longer it's going to go uh
and or what the repercussions will be in
terms of the counting of the ballot and
as i said earlier i think it would be
very important to finish the count today
and not to allow this to succeed i mean
they've succeeded in delaying it some
hours there's no question about that
but it really should not be allowed to
succeed
in any kind of uh in any kind of serious
way
i do want to pull up the washington post
feed as well
because they've been covering this and
they do a good job
um and actually it sounds like libby
casey is explaining what's going on
let's listen law enforcement on site to
control the mob
that's exactly right and when this all
began when we were first evacuated i
spoke with
a staffer who she right then and there
was was very
scared and that was early on in this
before uh the breach occurred and she
said i've never seen anything like this
and i asked her well why do you think
we're all being you know forced into the
basement
and she's like i really think it's
because the capitol police are stretched
in they can't
be in here and protect all of us in
different parts of the capital and
uh you know save off the people who are
outside
uh trying to get in so they have to pick
where they need to be and where they
need to put full force
and right now is trying to get people to
not come inside so that is why she said
we were probably uh put into the
basement area really early on because
they saw this threat coming
uh this is just you know as you said
this is
this is an end to trumpism and it's also
you know this is not about
being a republican and being upset about
an election this is a whole other
element
this is something that we just have not
seen in our modern history
and it is because of the rhetoric of the
president and also
the uh republicans in the senate who uh
you know
you and me and james we were talking the
the week of the
general election about when will mitch
mcconnell come out and say that
uh biden won when will these republican
leaders here is video of the
of certain officers taking pictures
actually taking pictures with the
protesters
hey calf hey calf unbelievable
hey truly unbelievable
truly unbelievable uh
wow chuck schumer who's the ranking
democrat in the senate
both asking president trump to speak to
his reporters
to urge them to leave the capitol so
these requests are coming into the
president from the democratic leadership
from the republican leadership we have
the vice president of the united states
calling on these protesters to stand
down saying they will be
they will be prosecuted he said to the
full extent
of the law my colleague nick schifrin
who covers national security
covers the military the pentagon and the
state department for us nick with some
information nick
you want to go ahead yeah judy over the
last uh
hour or so it's been really back and
forth when it comes to the national
guard uh
d.c national guard uh deploys
through the pentagon whereas the
virginia and maryland nationals guard
national guards would deploy uh through
their governors after being asked
uh we now have confirmation from the
pentagon
that the d.c national guard will deploy
uh into washington dc and the area
around the capitol
a statement from chief pentagon
spokesman jonathan hoffman
the question is when it has been
mobilized to provide support to federal
law enforcement in the district
uh and then discusses how the acting
secretary of defense
chris miller has been in contact with
congressional leadership
uh and the army secretary mccarthy has
been working with the d.c government
that's led of course
by the mayor and the statement goes on
to say the law enforcement response
will be led by the department of justice
and and judy that
speaks to fears within the pentagon
uh until this afternoon i should say
that the dc
guard would be misused there were a lot
of concerns how the d.c national guard
deployed in june during the george floyd
protests
and so joint staff uh leaders pentagon
leaders army leaders took pains
to restrict how the guard could be
deployed
they weren't allowed as of this morning
to have weapons they weren't allowed to
have
any armored vehicles and they weren't
allowed to use any helicopters like they
did in june
but again that was as of this morning so
this is new this is just in the last
hour or so
the dc national guard has been activated
the entire guard all 1100 has been
activated
because of what's happening at the
capitol and they will be
assisting law enforcement in clearing
the capital wow
just one more nick in an extraordinary
turn of events this afternoon
you have the d.c national guard as
you're reporting earlier we have been
reporting both virginia the governor
ralph northam of virginia
said that the virginia national guard
was going into the district to help
uh at the request of of mayor bowser so
we are
presumably just moments from hearing
from joe biden i
i know i've fallen behind on thank yous
i do want to thank the 53 people who
just grabbed twitch prime subscriptions
which is which is amazing
um and also another uh 26 people
signed up on my website putting us at
420
420 420 today uh and really appreciate
the support you can grab a membership at
joinpacman.com it's really quick it's
really easy
and we continue to follow what it is
that is going on in washington dc for
the time being the actual count of the
ballots has been stopped
um it has been stopped due to this
insurrection taking place with the
breach of the capitol building
it is all shut down it would be very
important
uh resume uh as as quickly as possible
to prevent them from actually
having the impact of delaying this even
a day and we knew
it could go late into the night or maybe
technically into tomorrow
but it shouldn't be allowed to go any
later than that and so hopefully they
are going to be
resuming the count maybe in another
location
um relatively soon so we continue to
uh this door oh so now somebody's
speaking on a megaphone let's see
news organizations uh i heard him say
kaylee mcinerney at the beginning of his
statements
so i think he's letting them know that
the president is sending in national
guard troops and hasn't proved that
so now he's inciting the mob to go
attack journalists
oh my god oh no that's not bad i was
gonna say oh good they're saying go home
now it sounds like he's the guy is
reportedly saying go attack journalists
organizations
[Applause]
let's go back to rhonda coleman rhonda
sorry to interrupt you i was interested
to see what the mob would do
when they uh learned that the president
has called for the national guard to
come
and i think we have an answer that one
of them is asking them to go attack
the hard-working journalists of america
so in the meantime rhonda i i wanted to
get back to you at this issue that
that democrats are having to be the ones
to sort of call for a restoration of
order here
uh in much louder voices than republican
leadership
yeah you know that's right and that kind
of goes part of the course of what we've
seen over the last four years i i've
spent
many hours pre-coded of course when uh
journalists were able
all right so we are seeing that we are
seeing that
and then let's take a listen here if you
can pan a little bit that way judy i
want to show you
there's still a significant contingent
of people
on that center stairwell but even that
has thinned out
just a bit so if i were to update people
on sort of what's been happening out
here
there's definitely fewer protesters
maybe because of the cold
the tear gas also contributed a little
bit but people are by and large
starting to leave some of this location
you'll see some folks walking around
behind us as well there's now many more
heavily armed guards law enforcement
officials
some who we saw with emergency response
vests on who have taken up a position
outside the perimeter
and seem to be part of that line now
holding people back
there's a handful of dc capital police
who have been here from the beginning
who are still in those same positions
but again fewer protesters now engaged
in direct confrontation
now down to sort of a smaller hardware
at a certain point you have to set a
perimeter and anybody who crosses it
gets arrested right i mean it's like at
some point you have to set a limit
enforcement
we have not yet seen any significant
arrival
of national guard troops or any other
reinforcement troops
we're hearing fire sirens and we see
cars pull up every now and again
but i have to tell you from here judy we
haven't seen a significant increase
in that kind of heavier law enforcement
or official presence we'll let you know
as we do but
maybe they're hoping that sort of over
time as the cold overtakes people and
the tear gas is deployed that
the crowd will continue to thin out
here's joe biden
tensions seem to have gone down just a
little bit
but we'll come back to you as we know
more judy all right amna thank you from
outside the capitol and now to joe biden
speaking to the press in wilmington
delaware
oh great there's no audio oh there it is
i've been watching
at this hour our democracy is under
unprecedented assault
unlike anything we've seen in modern
times
an assault on the citadel of liberty
the capitol itself
an assault on the people's
representatives
and the capitol hill police sworn to
protect them
and the public servants who work
at the heart of our republic
an assault on the rule of law
like few times we've ever seen it
an assault on the most sacred of
american undertakings
the doing of the people's business
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must
end now
i call on this mob to pull back and
allow the work of democracy to go
forward
you've heard me say before in different
contexts
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
at their worst they can incite
and therefore i call on president trump
to go on national television now
to fulfill his oath and defend the
constitution
and demand an end to this siege
to storm the capital to smash windows
to occupy offices the floor of the
united states senate
rummaging through desks on the capitol
on the
house of representatives threatening the
safety of duly elected officials it's
not
protest it's insurrection right
the world's watching like so many other
americans
i am genuinely shocked and saddened that
our nation
so long the beacon of light and hope for
democracy
has come to such a dark moment
through war and strife america has
endured much
and we will endure here and we will
prevail again
and will prevail now the work of the
moment
and the work of the next four years must
be the restoration
of democracy of decency honor
respect the rule of law
just plain simple decency
the renewal of the politics it's about
solving problems looking out for one
another
not stoking the flames of hate and chaos
as i said america is about honor
decency respect tolerance
that's who we are that's who we've
always been
the certification electric the electoral
college vote
is supposed to be a sacred ritual which
we affirm
purposes to affirm the majesty of
american democracy
but today's reminder a painful one
that democracy is fragile and to
preserve it
requires people of good will leaders
the courage to stand up who are devoted
not to the pursuit of power
but with a interests pursuits of their
own
selfish interest at any cost but of the
common good
i think what our children watching
television is thinking
think what the rest of the world is
looking at
for nearly two and a half centuries
we the people in search of a more
perfect union
ever kept our eyes on that common good
america's so much better than what we've
seen today
watching the scenes from the capitol
i was reminded as i prepared other
speeches in the past i was reminded of
the
words of abraham lincoln and his annual
message to congress
whose work has today been interrupted by
chaos
here's what lincoln said
he said we shall nobly save or merely
lose
the last best hope on earth
went on to say the way is plain
peaceful generous just
a way which if followed
the world will forever applaud
and god must forever bless
the way is plain here too that's who we
are
it's the way of democracy of respect
of decency of honor
and commitment as patriots to this
nation
notwithstanding what i saw today we're
seeing today
i remain optimistic about the incredible
opportunities
there's never been anything we can't do
when we do it together
and this god-awful display today
is bringing home to every republican and
democrat and independent in the nation
that we must step up this is the united
states of america there's never
ever ever ever ever been a thing we've
tried to do
that we've done it together we've not
been able to do it
so president trump step up
may god bless america may god protect
our troops and all those folks at the
capitol
who are trying to preserve order thank
you and i'm sorry to have kept you
waiting
wow apologizing for running late talking
uh to the press there i basically agree
with everything other than biden saying
it's just a couple of people that are
the problem it's more than just a couple
of people it's not nearly everyone it's
not even half the country
uh but oh hold on you heard joe biden
describe the
what he called disorder and chaos at the
capitol he said this
borders on sedition it must end
i call on this mob i'm reading joe
biden's words
to pull back and he went on to speak
about the word
yeah so so overall um uh completely
completely reasonable
and and much needed speech and there
goes
uh joe let's see what
my safety he's or the inauguration
i am not concerned the american people
are going to stand
up and stand up now enough
is enough is enough okay oh so i think
the question that was asked was is joe
biden worried about his security around
the inauguration
and he said uh no he said that uh that
that
that is not a concern uh for him at this
point in time
so the uh crowd continues we are
anticipating that the
uh national guard is very very close to
showing up so here's what i think we're
going to do
we've been live for three and a half
hours and
uh i think what i'm going to do is i'm
going to end this stream
and work on tomorrow's show a little bit
because i don't want to get up at 5am
and then once the curfew starts
and maybe the counting resumes and the
national guard arrives which we're
expecting to be
in the next couple of hours uh we'll get
another stream going and i will be back
with everybody okay so
that's the plan thanks for joining me if
you subscribe
free on youtube and follow on twitch
you'll be notified when i go back live
in a couple of hours alright we'll see
everybody soon
you